okay I want to ask her there any health
professionals in here this morning any
doctors nurses Indian chiefs okay good
we appreciate them let's give them a
hand and what you're gonna see is an
adaption of a presentation I gave to the
United Nations
August 7th of this year or actually last
year a couple of months ago and so
you'll notice that there's quite a bit
of stuff from like 20 different
countries because one of the United
Nations to understand that what what I'm
sharing is a thing of humanity as
opposed to America alone and so but it
all tells the same story and so we'll
get going and if you would hold the
questions then we'll have plenty of time
for Q&A afterwards and this will be
considerably different from what you've
learned okay everybody we're supposed to
be okay here we go the thing that makes
me different is that I have a degree in
agriculture I have a degree in
veterinary medicine I'm a comparative
pathologist where I do autopsies on
animals and people and I've been a
primary care physician as an HPA
physician licensed in Oregon in
California since 1978 so some of the
stuff you're appreciated for the United
Nations somebody go fairly fast and I
also received the Lifetime Achievement
Award there on natural medicine
philanthropy very proud of that now how
many of you raise your hand if you ever
heard the CD audio cassette tape of the
book dead doctors don't lie
okay good a few only about 1% 2% we've
sold 350 million copies of the CD 10
million copies of the book and I'm
telling you that not to brag because I
want you to be understanding of the
perspective where we're coming from
Michael Jackson's Thriller his
bestseller he sold 72 million the Bible
has sold trillions right hmm and so
we're putting things in perspective
why dead doctors don't live because the
average lifespan according to their own
survey the medical system published
six medical journals in 1999 is
fifty-six God lives forever we need to
listen to God why do we spend so much
time and energy and attention to doctors
whose average lifespan according to
their own survey is 56 the information
I'm going to share this morning is in my
newest book one of 14 books epigenetics
and it's the number one bestseller
according to amazon.com in the field of
genetics epigenetics and general
medicine in the last couple of months
I'm very very proud of that okay here's
the beginning of the presentation this
is December 1st 2008 Time magazine cover
article the sorry state of American
health we don't have the best health
care system the world where the most
expensive health care system er but not
the best and what they said here was
that despite technological advances in
medicine Americans are less healthy than
we used to be and the most terrible part
of this story is that it says that our
children will be the first generation of
Americans who do not live as long as
your parents how many of you heard that
raise your hand okay that's about 10%
our children are not gonna live as long
as us if we continue doing what we're
doing well the reason why I'm on this
crusade and speak 400 times a year
because I'm not prepared to accept that
prediction I'm not gonna just shrug my
shoulders over well that's the way it is
I'm prepared to fight until my dying
breath to save as many kids as we can
okay and because
I believe this is a mission that the
good Lord gave me and I'm gonna carry it
out and that's what we're talking about
grandma died at 92 mom died at night at
64 and daughter and granddaughter died
at 46 this is a word cloud obviously and
you have to appreciate that
over the centuries going back five six
seven thousand years ago in the days of
the Pharaohs there's been thousands of
failed medical and scientific theories
every century in the 20th century in
21st century are no different there's
thousands of failed medical theories
let's just look at some of the more
common ones obesity how many heard of
the word obesity okay good
we're in the church so you do have to
answer honestly and the theory for 125
years and obesity has been that people
are overweight and obese 35 pounds or
more of their ideal weight for their
height because they don't exercise
enough they eat too much that's been the
prevailing theory that's been used in
addition to surgeries and gastric bypass
drugs but the basic concept to lose
weight is to eat less and exercise more
and what do we get that for the last
hundred twenty-five years what did we
get from that theory we're number one
for the number one obese nation in the
world we have more fitness centers
people are exercising more than ever
eating less I mean you go on television
those will fix your meals for you all
that kind of stuff and yet we're still
the number one obese nation in the world
it turns out that obesity has nothing to
do with how much exercise and it's only
secondary how much eat because the
symptoms of a deficiency of a class of
nutrients will cause you to have the
munchies if you choose poorly and eat
things that have lots of easy calories
you're going to gain weight if you
choose things to eat that don't have
easy calories in them you won't gain
weight exercise effectively has nothing
to do with your obese or not it's a
deficiency you take the nutrients and it
goes away at the rate of a half a pound
of 2 pounds a day with the exercise or
not now let's look at alzheimers disease
Allisyn disease when it was first
recognized 45 years ago never existed
even by another name and certainly not
genetic the big theory of it originally
was was it was caused by aluminum how do
how many of you heard of the aluminum
theory of Allison disease well that's a
failure turns out that aluminum is an
essential nutrient for a succinate
enzyme required for metabolism your
mitochondria inside your cells so then
if it's not genetic and it's not
aluminum what causes Allison disease as
a simple deficiency disease was caused
by medical doctors who took if you will
a bribe from Procter and Gamble to
demonize cholesterol and saturated fat
to sell another product and the result
of demonizing cholesterol and saturated
fat and cholesterol lowering drugs is
many many diseases which we'll talk
about in a few moments the most
egregious one of course is Allison
disease it's a physician cause disease
easily prevented and easily reversed
we'll talk about that in detail
cardiovascular disease raise your hand
if you've ever heard it has something to
do with with saturated fat and
cholesterol remember you're in church
and I ask it again how many of you heard
that cholesterol and saturated fat have
something whether you believe it or not
have something to do with cardiovascular
right now it turns out that congestive
heart failure very common cause of heart
death in adults is a deficiency have a
single vitamin we've known that for 300
years it was discovered by a Japanese
naval surgeon 300 years ago is caused by
deficiency of a single vitamin and it's
easily reversed in just a couple of days
5 10 15 20 days a month at the most very
easy to get rid of you don't have to
have a heart transplant you don't have
to be on medication for 25 years praise
God
and then cardi mopti heart disease the
thing that kills athletes suddenly are
people who drop dead well they're doing
hard physical work is caused by
deficiency of a single mineral I've
personally done 1,700 autopsies on kids
under the age of 10 that have died of
that one big government project and then
there's coronary heart disease where you
have plugged arteries that doesn't is
not caused by closure on saturated fat
that's caused by inflammation how many
view heard of the inflammation kind of
concept
okay well inflammation causes your
arteries to react and put out scar
tissue to protect themselves from this
irritating like pouring acid through
your veins and arteries
and the scar tissue plugs your eyes when
you do special stains on the plaque in
your arteries there's no cholesterol in
saturated fat it's all scar tissue it's
easily gotten rid of easily prevented
without surgery without bypasses you may
need a stent once awhile for an
emergency sort of thing and then
coronary thrombosis we get a blood clot
in the coronary artery it has nothing to
do with cholesterol saturated fat it's
actually a deficiency of it make it 3
essential fatty acid deficiency or ratio
plum in your diet of omega-3s sixes and
nines and you see so many omega-3
products advertised on radio and TV
because of this in the newspapers and
that's one of my nine lawsuits against
the FDA in which I prevailed in all nine
cases hypertension is not a genetic
disease even in the black community it's
a simple deficiency of nutrients easily
eliminated very quickly arthritis is not
genetic has nothing to do with age
babies are born with arthritis it's a
combination deficiency of vitamins and
minerals and then type-2 diabetes has
nothing to do with genetics type-2
diabetes is a simple deficiency of a
single mineral we've known that for 80
years I actually back in the 1960s
discovered a type 2 diabetes and
crocodiles and alligators and I was
wondering how did a crocodile from
Africa get human genetic disease he must
have been eating Baptist preachers that
had diabetes in Africa or something it
turns out that this one deficiency this
one mineral universally gives diabetes
to any vertebrate whether they're a
crocodile or a snake or a hummingbird or
a deer or a human being it doesn't
matter again some of this stuff I had to
educate all these ambassadors so we're
gonna flip through a lot of this stuff
witches were burned at the stake witches
are usually grandmas who are using herbs
and chicken soup to heal people make him
feel better and the medical system
didn't like that and so they would go to
churches and say grandma Ruthie is a
witch she's using witchcraft to cure
people who said church's job to cure
people so the churches of the day would
send out inquisition committees to
torture these poor animals until they
admitted to and confessed to being a
witch
using witchcraft and then they were
rewarded by being burned at the stake
and the doctors were happy all the way
to the bank
the FDA and the medical system their
limit of nutrition as the four food
groups for a long time for about 50
years we used a seven food group here
mean how do you remember the seven food
group pyramid okay well that was too
complicated for the FDA the government
and medical doctors so they reduced it
to the four food groups now remember
this is what we're doing and this is why
we're sicker than we've ever been this
is why we're dying younger and younger
and this is why your children will not
live as long as you you cannot get
everything you need from the four food
groups because the nutrition is not in
the food anymore we'll talk about that
in a moment
the original pharmaceuticals for the
doctor would give you something in his
office was homebrew is whiskey and you
know good Kentucky Bourbon and that kind
of stuff one of the big ones was
coca-cola coca-cola before prescriptions
coca-cola was cocaine that's why they
called it coca-cola and in the 1920s it
became a prescription item cocaine for
dentistry primarily in the beginning and
so they had to take it out of the
coca-cola the over-the-counter in the
end the drugstore stuff they were
pulling out of the little things and the
Tampa goes you called it
and today coca-cola is one of the
biggest export products to the world
this is how people know us Oh coca-cola
that's that's the American thing and
then before the drugs prozac and others
for depression doctors would prescribe
cigarettes call for Philip Morris I'd
walk a mile for a camel and it's always
a doctor and his white coat and a
stethoscope he'd walk a mile for a camel
there's probably wiser average lifespan
is 56 hospitals over charged patients by
a thousand percent they'll charge you
five hundred bucks for a three cent late
text examining glove and nobody pays
attention because insurance pays or
Medicare pays when you get the statement
in the mail you just throw it in a jar
or burn it throw in the trash nobody
sits there and goes item behind him to
see what you were charged every time
doctors go on strike who work for the
hospitals are on the hospital's
as opposed to owning your own clinic
every time doctors go on strike in
hospitals all over the world where's
England or Israel United States the
death rate goes down that's a fact you
can google it death rate in hospitals
when doctors are on strike people don't
die anymore this doctor Jerry Blanc from
Tulsa Oklahoma I go there quite often
there's so many churches in Tulsa
Oklahoma is called Tulsa Russa ylim
because there's so many churches there
and he was fined a hundred and five
thousand dollars which is chump change
dat him for miss billing Medicare he
would charge people for things he didn't
do he would charge people for things he
did that they didn't need and one
hundred and five thousand dollars was
not a big deal for him was kind of chump
change to him but when two hundred
patients lined up to sue him for five to
ten million dollars each because they
had he'd cut things off that they didn't
have to have done but he needed the
money he jumped off a 20-story building
committed suicide October of 2015
prescription drug abuse is reaching
crisis proportions right now 59 percent
of American adults are on five or more
prescription drugs the medical system
has failed as terribly here and
primarily they'd like to use addictive
drugs such as opioids why do they do
that because you have to come in every
month get your prescription fulfilled
that way they keep getting the office
fees okay
it became such a big story as a cover
story in Time magazine in June of 2015
this is one of my favorite articles a
full page article and hedges chop it up
a little bit came out
February 5th 2007 full page article in
USA Today the title is a little vanilla
for me patient protect thy self and the
line which appears to be aligned just
above patient protect thy self is really
a list of some of the sources that they
got the information from the Institute
of Medicine the ethics watchdog for the
medical system the journal the American
Medical Association the most prestigious
medical journals certainly in America
maybe the world and then the Center for
Disease Control which is a federal
agency the Traxxas stuff and the figure
I'm gonna give you which came from those
agencies is a yearly figure this is not
a hundred years of accumulated data this
is a yearly figure according to them and
that's in the kind of upper left-hand
corner under medical mistakes it says
each year in America each year in
American medical doctors kill injure and
infect 15 million patients right here in
America alone each year american medical
doctors kill injured in fact 15 million
patients each year let's just look at
2006 again this is the Institute of
Medicine did a study they just looked at
decimal point errors for the prescribing
physician actually have some decimal
mistakes are they're fulfilling
pharmacists and made some decimal point
mistakes these types of mistakes yearly
figure are tallied up at one point five
million fatalities and permanent
injuries each year from decimal point
mistakes and prescriptions let's just
look at infections in hospitals each
year just American Hospital this is a
Center for Disease Control the federal
agency the tracks and stuff they said
that there's two million infections each
year from one bug c-diff classroom
difficile which is a human poop bacteria
and they tracked it through hidden
cameras the doctors just don't wash
their hands after they go potty things
that you things that you teach a
three-year-old to do doctors don't wash
your hands after they go potty and
results in 2 million infections each
year in households and of those two main
infections you look at the second
paragraph on the left-hand column it
says of these 2 million patients are
infected each year in hospitals 90,000
die
each year 90,000 died from these
infections doctors simply don't wash
their hands after your party I'm gonna
give you a theoretical problem here
what if North Korea what if Iran what if
Isis were to send over an
intercontinental ballistic missile with
a biological weapon infect large
population centers like Newark New
Jersey Philadelphia what about New York
what about Atlanta what about Dallas
Texas what about LA what about Chicago
in fact two million people with that
biological weapon and killed 90,000 it'd
be war
wouldn't it here's one trade that does
it every year in their office their
workplace they don't even get an OSHA
ticket they get a walk every time that's
because people make the mistake of
loving their doctor more than they love
God
I want you to appreciate that every time
you see something the newspaper that a
certain drug has been recalled because
it's wounding or hurting people or a
device medical device such as the
endoscopes from above and the and the
Columbus Copic examination from below or
hurting people they pull them off the
market the FDA will pull them off the
market well when they withdraw these
things whether it's the drugs or the
medical devices guess what the FDA is
the one who approved them they approved
him taking the advice without challenge
from the people who made them there's
all this hanky panky under the table
death rates rising for middle-aged white
Americans because they're all getting on
these opioid drugs from the doctors this
doctor who built four surgeries that
were not performed particularly he said
they people had cancer
he got a hundred and seventy five years
in prison this is from Detroit but I
guarantee he won't spend that much time
there he'll get out in two years medical
guesswork when doctors don't know what
you have they won't say you know I
really don't know I want to give you
another appointment next week for free
and you come in and in the meantime
between now and then I'm going to
contact the University I'm going to
contact CDC and I'll have some answers
for you in a couple weeks instead
they'll always say you have an
autoimmune disease your body's attacking
itself and I can help your symptoms but
I I can't totally deal with this disease
because your body's attacking a cell we
might say did your mom or dad have this
because he's looking for genetics right
and did your brother and sisters have it
no no and then he gets desperate and
he'll say does your dog have it each
surgeon United States makes thousands of
errors each year he's surgeon United
States makes thousands of heirs yearly
this was first shown in 1990 by Lucien
lepay who's a head of department of
public health at the Harvard School of
Medicine 1919 he did it again in 2014
and you know we're talking about take
out the normal lung leave the cancers
lung in cut off your right leg when you
should have taken your left cataract out
give you a heart replacement when you
just went in there you just went in
there to have a stent put in how does
this happen
well according to Lucien lepay the head
of department of public health at
Harvard Medical School 1990 in 2014 he
said and he did this study he went and
got blood samples from these doctors
saying hey we're doing a study on
doctors and they just volunteered and
gave their blood on hundreds of them he
found out that 52 percent of the doctors
in emergency rooms and surgical suites
in their private clinics 52%
executed everyday when they go to work
on alcohol street drugs and prescription
drugs we did it again in 2014 got the
same answer know what I want you to do
is email your federal and state
representatives your federal and state
senators your governor's your presidents
and ask that doctors have to breathe
into a breathalyzer test before they're
allowed your key won't work in their
office if they're not sober and they
have to have pee in front of a nurse
into a cup because I don't want to bring
their dogs urine right they have to pee
in the cup and then the nurse will have
a test strip to put in their screen for
drugs and if he passes everything every
morning he gets to go to work
if he flunks he goes to jail for three
months and has his license taken away
why should you suffer death and injury I
mean you would they test athletes when
they win a gold medal they test them for
drugs are gonna sakes calf scams caused
cancer one cat scan gives you the
radiation of 500 chest x-rays even the
government says don't get them there is
a a procedure called a high-resolution
ultrasound which will give you the same
information as a cat scan but the doctor
only makes $50 for the high-resolution
ultrasound he makes $2,500 from a cat
scan mammograms are not prevention one
mammogram gives the radiation of 500
chest x-rays ladies so your doctor
insists that you must have a mammogram
what you do is this doctor I've been
your patient for 10 15 20 years whatever
it is and I really appreciate you as I
keep coming to you and I know you're
probably insisting that I do this
mammogram because you're concerned about
my health but I'm concerned about the
safety I've been reading a lot of things
in the papers and seeing things on TV
and hearing on the radio and that
there's a problem with the safety of
mammogram so I want you to prove to me
that it's safe and then I'll do it if
you can prove to me and save I'm doing
the doctor if he's smart he'll stay well
okay how can I help you how can i what
can I do what question can I answer for
you to help you feel comfortable the
safety of a mammogram and ladies here's
which is
sir if you'll put your testicles in that
machine
[Applause]
whoa
remember I'm quoting you now ladies I am
woman and I guarantee you there will
never be another recommendation for a
mammogram
[Applause]
this is obviously a Canadian story and
it deals with an American story that was
put out in 2011 by the US Department of
Health and Human Services a presidential
cabinet post supervises this a US
Surgeon General and it became a Canadian
story and what they're saying is that
each month each month in America medical
doctors kill 15,000 seniors over the age
of 65 because they send them in for
unnecessary screening tests and what
they would call minor procedures that's
180 thousand year seniors that are
killed by unnecessary testing and
procedures because the doctor needs the
income to pay his bills
now most people didn't read this article
because the headline intimates that this
is a governmental problem u.s. health
care weighs seven hundred fifty billion
dollars here's what's new if the
government wastes a lot of money and so
what should be surprising there but this
is not that what the story said what the
story said was your doctor your primary
care physician your GP actually bills
for things he didn't do like that guy
that went to prison four hundred seventy
five years and he bills for things he
did do to you but you didn't need
because he didn't want to pay back a
student loan
he just bills you you pay him he pays
the universe he doesn't have to pay it
back he uses you as an ATM machine at
this point I have to tell you a little
story and you'll see some of this in a
moment I worked a lot with the
african-american and the black community
all over the world since 1991 and
there's reasons for that which I'll get
to in a moment but just before she died
and credits got King called me because
I've been working with her son Martin
Luther King the third and with his
weight problem and and diabetes and so
forth and she said to me in in her condo
I spent four hours with her by she and I
alone as I was a blessing what a great
woman and she said to me yes
[Applause]
dr. Wallach I'm dying of cancer you know
the universities and the cancer doctors
have given up on me I've only got months
to live and it's time for the march from
the Ebenezer Baptist Church to the Kings
Center for dr. King's birthday and I
want to March one last time she does I
don't think I can physically make it and
and she had all kinds of terrible
complications for her her cancer as well
mrs. King would you like me to help you
with your cancer she doesn't know I've
already made up my mind I'm ready to be
with Martin and I really just want to do
this one last March so she shared with
me what her complications were what her
restrictions were we came up with a
program and and praise God she was able
when the time came she was able to
complete that March so we give God all
the credit on that one right but the
beautiful thing out of that four hours
that I spent with Coretta Scott King was
this I said ma'am I have I have one
question to ask you if I may about dr.
King [__] oh please anything I said well
when dr. King knew he'd won the civil
rights movement when he knew legislation
was coming did he kind of fold his
tenancy okay it's time to retire and I
can just go back to preaching in my
church sure you know what was his
thinking when he won such a great great
thing she said oh that wasn't the end
for him that was just the beginning
she said the medical system was next
because he knew that the medical system
in the US and this is all in my newest
book which is the bestseller Mitchell's
as you've seen Minh to great detail with
dr. King knew how many of you heard of
the Tuskegee experimental okay that was
one of the nicest things that the
medical system ever did the black people
compared all the terrible things that
were done to them and their most of them
are listed in that book of epigenetics
and there was a horrible thing she said
dr. King knew this and he was going
after the medical system next to make
sure that the the black community was
not taken advantage of okay not being
used as an ATM machine not being used as
an
animal in 1980 it was one out of 250,000
kids had autism now it's one out of 45
how that happened well there's two
reasons number one there's enormous
incentive there's enormous incentive for
a pediatrician to diagnose a child with
autism because the statistics are over a
five-year period with an autistic kid
regardless of the age over a five-year
period the doctor will the pediatrician
will make two million dollars so why
wouldn't every kid that comes in have
autism secondly the brain requires 90
essential nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamin 12 amino acids 3 fatty acids and
our children don't even have half a
chance to get that anymore when I was a
kid for breakfast we'd have beets and we
have sweet potatoes and we'd have eggs
have steak for breakfast or a hamburger
patty today they got fruity pebbles and
apple juice on the way to the daycare
center
this little Latino girl 28 years old was
from a low-income family and so she was
using county facilities for her prenatal
care and when she got pregnant for her
pregnancy monitoring the day came to
have her baby the doctor had been
monitoring her they paged him and he's
playing golf he's on the 14th hole nice
oh this is her first pregnancy to take a
little while keep me informed and so 45
minutes later they page him again all
this baby's crown his baby's coming
quick got to be here there's no other
doctors here if she needs a caesarean if
the baby needs something special there's
nobody here to do anything you got to be
here doctor we came in 45 minutes later
just as the baby was crowning and he
goes right through the scrub room didn't
wash his hands cut her arms and legs off
and then delivered the baby now he did
it six months later to another woman who
had interrupted his golf game he's still
working at that County Hospital in
Orlando Florida because it's a County
Hospital it's a government house one
with a big Union they can't fire him
I've heard daddy if I was her daddy I'd
have been I'd have been found guilty of
temporary insanity
and that fella would not hurt anybody
else
this is in England this was a delivery
where the mother had a very small pelvic
canal through her pelvis was obvious the
baby's not gonna be able to be delivered
normally and so they had planned in
advance for a c-section and I don't know
why maybe he's intoxicated maybe he's
just in a hurry but he entered his hands
into the birth canal and pulled on the
baby's head and pulled the baby's head
off from the from this from the neck
vertebrae the skin was still there just
holding the head on so he pushes the
baby back in then he does it cesarean
section oh this baby was born in this
way well fortunately a nurse reported
him and I had to find out what the
follow-up is there's not a single
disease that's caused by genetics the
concept of disease being caused by
genetics is an overreach by the medical
system and the scientific community back
in the days of Darwin back in the early
1800s he knew that in Scotland where the
mother had read here in the father had
read here all babies had red hair also
in Scotland or Ireland couples had had
black hair maybe out of every ten baby
there'd be one born with red hair and
they thought there was hanky-panky going
on at the time right but they kind of
realized by doing animal things in
agriculture that there's messages that
both a mother and father give the baby
and there was hidden messages and they
could appear sometimes in the babies
whether it was an animal or human and
then of course with the Gregor Mendel's
pea experiments he was a priest and did
this sort of thing they began to think
of genetics then every time a baby's
born with the problem it was genetic
what turns out that all birds defects
I'm gonna repeat that all birth defects
are caused by nutritional deficiencies
the embryo even sickle-cell anemia
I'm finding sickle cell anemia and
hummingbirds and deer and antelope I'm
finding sickle cell anemia and white
folks but it's called thalassemia and
white folks because you can't have black
jeans and white folks or white jeans
black folks they give it the same as
these different names
I mean come on you got to protect your
industry right well 1961 on a on a grant
from the National Institutes of Health
actually I take that back that's not
true I'm dancing I'm ahead of myself
here in 1961 I actually ran into the
first mass die-off in America from
pollution 1961 I was a graduate student
I'd already graduated agricultural
school at the University of Missouri was
into my third year of veterinary school
and so as a graduate student and I was
taking pathology courses it was December
61 when all the professor's were off in
the graduate students were in charge of
the services and I was in charge of the
services for pathology and it ran into
the first mass now from pollution did
all the chemistry's got it right and
published it and so I was published at
age 21 had with a scientific study in
venery journals medical journals and
books well
after graduating veterinary school
Marlin Perkins Field mutual Omaha Wild
Kingdom show on TV I had worked for him
during the summer times as a kid he sent
me to to central in South Africa what is
now Zimbabwe which needs to be Southern
Rhodesia and the Republic of South
Africa back in the 60s and he was 66 67
I was there two years and my job was to
catch
Ryann and white rhino because they were
on the on the list where they were going
to be rare and endangered and go extinct
there's only 400 left south of the
Zambezi River and I caught 200 them half
of them sent it back to the States
so if you see a white rhino in a zoo or
wild animal park it's either one that I
caught or offsprings are the ones that I
caught so I'm very proud of that we
saved the species now there's 10,000 of
them both in the wild and in captivity
combined so it was a great project after
two years of working on that Perkins
sends me a letter saying he's got this
this grant from the National Institutes
of Health and since I had given him a
copy that paper on the mast down from
pollution he wanted me to be the
pathologist on the project because we're
gonna study pollution and it was called
the Centre for the baggage of natural
systems as the department biology at
Washington University the st. Louis
Botanical Gardens and to make a long
story short this is the director Ron
Perkins with the biologist now as a
pathologist and after 10 years I had
done 20,000 autopsies 10 million
chemistry's 10 millions of special
stains and 17,000 some change of those
20,000 autopsies were were 454 species
new animals and then there were 3,000
humans the data from that provided the
information for 75 scientific papers are
published in medical journals and
veterinary journals and chemistry
journals but also the book contained all
the data from these 20,000 autopsies and
10 million chemistry's 1,200 pages it's
in the Smithsonian Institute is a
national treasure
when they sold them back in the nineteen
late 70s when it came out
it was selling for a hundred and forty
dollars apiece which was thought to be a
great price for a book like that because
back then a textbook was 30 bucks or 50
bucks so 140 bucks was just like
outrageous they printed 10,000 copies
the top medical publishing house in the
world WB Saunders and they sold him out
in two weeks 140 bucks apiece well today
if you can get one all beat up on eBay
or Amazon used books you can get one
that's all beat up and dog-eared and
underlined and highlighted and coffee
stains all over it for less than two
thousand dollars you better get it if
you can get one that's still in the box
and wrapped up in the cover was never
opened they're going for $25,000 each
because of the information it's gonna
cost a billion dollars to redo that
study and back then it cost him 25
million dollars to do the study said
it'd be a billion dollar so universities
are prepared to spend twenty five
thousand dollars for the book so you
want to be looking for him and used book
stores and things him might hit the
jackpot all birth defects again are
caused by nutritional deficiency the
embryos have nothing to do with genetics
the double helix structure was proposed
in 1953 by James Watson an American on
your left and Francis Crick a British
guy on your right they collaborated and
came up with the proposal that the
structure of DNA was a was a double
helix by 2003 to 2011 we'd mapped out
the human genome we knew all the human
genes and they had been placed on
various
his ohms and they attributed certain
diseases to each of the genes on the
chromosomes and 850 biotech companies
were farmed in over a period of 60 years
between 53 and 2013 they have spent has
spent more than I don't know similarly
810 trillion dollars worldwide looking
to find a way to genetically engineer
stuff to replace the bad genes and
people and get rid of disease over 60
year period they're unable to do this
and what we learned because of my study
and this is why the book is in the
smithsonian institute national treasure
sickle cell anemia is not a genetic
thing i can take a black woman with
sickle cell anemia and a black man with
sickle cell anemia and they have ten
kids and not one of them all have sickle
cell anemia because i'm gonna give her
everything she needs to make that embryo
perfect okay it's an in barn air
metabolism they call it and what it is
and again I'm the guy that discovered it
because I'm seeing these things in
hummingbirds and deer there's supposed
to be a black genetic disease but it's
in all these animals all these
vertebrates non-human it turns out it's
a birth defect of the bone marrow it's
kind of like a cleft palate in the bone
marrow and so when the bone marrow was
farming in the third to seventh week of
pregnancy there wasn't enough of the
right nutrients to farm perfect bone
marrow which makes hemoglobin and so the
hemoglobin in his farm from this defect
his dysfunctional hemoglobin is not
genetic now they didn't have the
knowledge to know back then it wasn't
genetic because the baby was born from
it or with it okay this that to them it
meant to a genetic the same disease and
white folks is thalassemia and then of
course another inborn error metabolism
you know there's not genetic kinetic has
a lactose intolerance when the lactase
enzyme mechanism is being formed in the
pancreas of it and the small intestines
early in pregnancy something's missing
mama doesn't do that properly and so if
you're gonna go to an ice cream party
and have some fun you need to take a
lactase enzyme capsule so be ready for
all the lactose same thing with type 1
diabetes is not genetic there's supposed
to be five hundred thousand per islet of
Langerhans of these beta cells which
manufacture insulin but in somebody
who's a type one they only have ten
not ten thousand just ten just barely
enough cells to make enough insulin so
that a little baby can be okay but once
they hit six eight ten years old pre pre
pubic they're growing rapidly because
the growth hormones coming out they
don't have enough insulin they and
they're recognized having type 1
diabetes lipid storage diseases
tay-sachs disease all these things are
thought to be genetic it turns out
they're just nothing but a inborn error
metabolism mom is missing something is
the baby's going down the assembly line
epigenetics is a current best-selling
book the death of the genetic theory
disease transmission you'll see why
witnesses said in a moment
that's me back in 1977 and black gene
lies this is a book and if I may I'm
gonna take my coat off because I'm
getting cooked by these lights up here
thank you thank you pastor okay um this
book publication was paid for by pastor
Creflo Dollar from Atlanta Georgia how
many of you heard of him okay good yeah
great gentleman he is white pastor
Chafee and and I was just so happy to
see that the pastor is here at the
church's know him and everybody knows
each other very well any rate back in
1991 I was introduced to him by Andy
Young who ever worked with a lot from
the civil rights movement mayor of
Atlanta and bastard United Nations and
he told me that that pastor dollars 11
year old daughter had a genetic form of
asthma that only black kids get and she
wasn't responding to the maintenance
medication for asthma and the doctors
had pulled pastor dollar aside and said
look she's not gonna make it she's one
of these kids is just is not gonna make
it so steal yourself prepare because
she's a child that's not gonna make it
so I was introduced to him at night
listen yeah we give her like five or six
different medications they tried for
months it doesn't work and they tried
different medications doesn't work well
maintenance medication for asthma works
to prevent asthma attacks and now it
doesn't cure it but it will prevent
asthma attacks so the reason I serve
surmised that she wasn't responding to
these drugs she wasn't absorbing them
she just wasn't absorbing them
and so I put on a gluten-free diet so
her intestines would recover because
when you're gluten intolerant you're
testing this lose the ability to absorb
things so I put on a gluten-free diet
gave her the 90 essential nutrients
appropriate for her body weight for 11
year old kid who's very skinny because
she's obviously not absorbing nutrients
and so forth and prey has gotten too
weak she was cured
pastor dollar unsolicited gave me a
large sum of money a check I said well I
didn't ask for anything pasties no no
this is not for you for you this is for
you to do the study to find out what
causes diseases were said to be genetic
in the black community that or not I
want to know how to prevent them I want
to know how to cure them so I spent the
money as he wished and came up with this
book and he bought the first hundred
thousand copies and we sell about a
million it easier every black child in
the world needs to read this book
because it goes into what causes how to
prevent and reverse sickle-cell anemia
asthma obesity type 2 diabetes
alessandra Z's cardiovascular disease
high blood pressure none of those things
are in fact genetic they're all simple
nutritional deficiency diseases easily
prevented and easily reversed it's all
in the book black gene lies there's
pastor dollar and now this 11-year old
girl who's now 30 who
[Applause]
okay this was a study I did in the
nineteen nineteen sixties when I came
back from Africa everyday just about
we're in the newspapers in central part
of the United States including Missouri
and Illinois and Indiana because of all
the work where we join all these authors
are finding all these diseases and of
course the senator wanted to let people
know we were spending their money well
and so they're sending out news releases
and Monsanto the chemical company had a
main office in st. Louis and they
donated a big hydroponic UNICEF building
that held these trays and racks and
watering systems and fertilizing systems
and you could grow soybeans you could
grow corn you could grow barley grass or
wheat whatever you wanted to grow in
their tomatoes and they opted to set it
up for barley grass so be almost like
giving a pasture to an animal in a cage
in the zoo and Marlin Perkins said to me
okay Wallach we need to find out if
we're gonna be wasting a lot of time
here or the animals gonna eat it first
of all secondly is it gonna be a benefit
to Mars it just something to play with
and roll around on given diary as more
things to clean up so find out for me so
make a long story short there is a pair
of mallard ducks simple barnyard ducks
in one of the zoo ponds and every spring
it happened to be spring they'd lay four
legs and they were being the eggs were
being fed to the various animals that
would eat eggs and so I said don't give
the four legs to the animals anymore but
I want you to start putting them to
refrigerate when you get 125 of them let
me know well three months later we had
125 of these fertile eggs and
refrigerators just like human frozen
embryos kind of thing right and I set up
four groups group number one got chopped
up head iceberg lettuce for six weeks
group number two got only the chopped up
hydroponically grown barley grass from
this new hydroponics unit group number
three the one that has the ruler on it
got the ralston purina scientifically
constructed duck pellets for raising
baby ducks you know the one with the you
notice it the one with the ruler on it
is like three times as big as the other
two groups and then the hydroponically
grown barley grass and duck pellets
together group number four I called it
the baby Huey group
because over five times bigger than the
number one number two groups say mother
father the mother and father eating the
same food for the entire two or three
months whatever it was to get the
hundred twenty-five eggs and the only
genetic difference between them was
summer boys and summer girls otherwise
genes are exactly the same because the
same mother father same food they got
for the period of time where they're
laying those fertile eggs and the only
one that got the the nutrients in such a
level that it allowed them to get the
genetic potential for health and
longevity and fending off disease and
size and fitness and so forth was the
one that got both the hydroponically
your own barley grass and duck pellets
have this experiment was written up in
scientific journals it's a big portion
of a book called rare earths urban cures
and also of course it became the first
scientific study done on the science of
epigenetics was in the mid 60's in 1967
I believe and I'm considered one of the
three fathers of the science of
epigenetics as a result of that one
little experiment have a pressure I
probably went too fast there apologize
hybrid pleasure and blacks not genetic
okay say simple nutritional deficiency
the death of the genetic theory disease
transmission remember James Watson he
was one along with Francis Crick
proposed the the double helix structure
of DNA and he was asked in March of 2013
to give a progress report where are we
at it been 60 years since they had
proposed in 1953 the structure of DNA
was a double helix and over those six
years there had not been one disease
cured with the genetic engineering there
been not one disease prevented with
genetic engineering what was going on
what were we going wrong what's our
status of genetics he gets up in front
of illustrious group in San Diego
California I was at the University of
California San Diego and the Salk
Institute was there to be the host and
there were three hundred and bited
people I was not one of them and 150 of
them half of them were Nobel Prize
winners from all
the world.they one of the best minds in
the world for this presentation the
other 150 were heads of departments of
genetics and biochemistry and chemistry
at medical schools all over North
America Canada United States and Mexico
he got from this illustrious group kind
of like I'm standing in front of you now
and I'm gonna quote him now he said you
can sequence the genes of a hundred and
fifty thousand people that have what we
believe are genetically transmitted
disease such as sickle cell anemia type
2 diabetes things like cancer you're not
going to cure a single person now I said
a few more things that I'm going to
quote him again he said because all the
experiments we've done over the last 60
years in genetics have been irrelevant
I guarantee at that moment every heart
in that room started palpitating
eyebrows went up people stopped
breathing and then he spoke for a little
bit more and then he said because
nothing we have thought to be Jacob
transmitted is it's all biochemistry aka
nutritional deficiencies and then they
fired him they fired him the National
Institutes of Health and you may
remember that they fired him
now the first 90 days of pregnancy the
first trimester is when the baby's going
down the assembly line if mother's
missing something it's kind of like
going down the assembly line to Detroit
and the guy who has to put in the fuel
pump has the other bathroom he doesn't
stop the line he doesn't have somebody
come in fill in maybe 40 cars go by oh
by the time he gets back there's 40 cars
without a fuel pump same thing is true
with a mother with that babies the
babies farming she has to have
everything perfect all 60 minerals all
16 vitamins 12 amino acids free fatty
acids an optical mouse to manufacture
that baby properly is God saw fit to
make us okay
after that 90 days it's all growth of
course you can see how a human embryo as
is developing requires stuff another way
of looking at this is you can take a
blueprint of your dream home by your
dream lot on a lake or the mountains and
you throw that blueprint onto the lot
and come back here later is that house
built no the deer ate the blueprint in
the weeds or chest-high there's no house
because you needed you needed skilled
craftsmen concrete layers carpenters
roofers you needed roofing shingles you
knew would you need a drywall you need a
brick and it all this stuff same way
with your genes they are nothing but a
blueprint doctors yet still believe that
genes are autonomous they're gonna do
what they're gonna do regardless of how
you eat what you do it's not genetics
anymore it's all epigenetics okay what
are OBGYNs doing wrong they should be
held accountable for all this that the
fact that our children I could live as
long as us so I'll be the first
generation in America that our children
who do not live as long as us that's
because when the woman first comes
whether she's an eighteen year old when
she's going there because she has PMS
she hasn't started her period and she's
concerned about that sort of stuff
are she going through menopause or
whatever yeah but those are the shell
bearing years the ob/gyn nor his nurse
either give them a CD a DVD or a
pamphlet or a booklet that says you must
take all 90 essential nutrients to
prevent birth defects what I want you to
do is
somebody in your family or somebody you
know or someone in your church family or
somebody in your workplace either they
are young kids are dating seriously are
they're getting engaged or they're
getting married don't give them money
don't give them gift certificates do not
give them towels for their initials
monogrammed on it don't give them a set
of linens to start their household you
give them the 90 essential nutrients so
you won't be a grandparent babysitting a
special-needs child a disease called MS
multiple sclerosis historically has been
a disease of thirty five to fifty year
old people when it's diagnosed depending
on the number of lesions in the brain
how severe they are you might live
another 25 years gradually getting worse
and worse worse and doctors try to
manage the symptoms but today babies are
being born with MS multiple sclerosis
and they die within the first two years
why because of free radicals fried foods
processed meats you know things like
deli slices damaged meats sausage ham
bacon Bologna salami pastrami pepperoni
jerky corned beefs Pam things like oils
microwave popcorn theater popcorn olive
oil coconut oil margins mayonnaise Hill
dressing cooking oils these turned into
trans fats which then caused this
inflammatory damage of the white matter
of the brain this is where you get ms
circulating around the mother's blood
goes into the baby's placenta it goes
into the baby and causes the problem in
babies we didn't have that stuff when I
was a kid because we didn't have those
types of foods tear rolls get strokes
now they get a blood clot in the brain
get a stroke and die that never happened
when I was a kid
strokes are caused by omega-3 essential
fatty acid deficiency it has nothing to
a cholesterol in saturated fat lupus is
a very simple nutritional deficiencies
it's not autoimmune I don't care if
you've had it for 30 years it's
reversible you get on a gluten-free diet
so you can absorb the nutrients you get
on all 90 essential nutrients a little
bit of what we call the secret sauce so
your body can rebuild itself and lo and
behold God works his magic down syndrome
you've all heard a Down syndrome
Down syndrome is caused by deficiency of
a single mineral in the first division
after the sperm fertilizes the egg your
one-celled human being and that minerals
there an optimal amounts the baby won't
get Down syndrome but if there's not
optimal amounts of that one mineral
there's a high probability that would be
a Down syndrome baby well up until about
25 30 years ago the word was amongst the
OBGYNs and middle-aged women that
middle-aged women over age 35 were more
apt to have a Down syndrome baby how
many heard that you know were 35 you're
more likely to have a Down syndrome baby
that was the way things are going well
today women in their 20s and teens who
get pregnant are the ones more likely to
have a Down syndrome baby now Down
syndrome is reversible in the first two
and a half months of pregnancy either an
amniocentesis tests are an ultrasound
you can see the baby has Down syndrome
and it's reversible at that point I've
done it many many times my most famous
one was Lauren Knievel Evel Knievel's
niece in law and it's it's one of those
God things I call you give the body what
it needs even as an embryo it will
repair itself serval pauls you've all
seen that in various degrees it's a
disease in which the cerebellum the
small part of the brain in the back
controls the fine motor movement as it's
underdeveloped because mama didn't have
everything she needed a nominal Mouse
for the proper time when that part of
the brain was developing and the degree
and the level level of severity of zero
palsy is directly related to how long
the mother's deficiency was how severe
the deficiency was and so forth this
girl cost you five five million dollars
a year to take care of her instead of
her cerebellum when she was a six pound
baby
severed her cerebellum being the size of
a small tangerine as the size of a grape
okay and so she's totally disabled but
she can have perfectly normal babies
because this isn't genetic she could
marry a perfectly normal young man she
can marry a boy with cerebral palsy and
they can use artificial insemination or
whatever you want to do how I get him
pregnant they can have a perfectly
normal baby as long as she is taking the
ninetieth sense of nutrients because
this is not genetic
and of course the cerebellum is that
piece it looks like a a great
participants life through in the lower
right hand corner or the brain the
smaller it is more catastrophic the
cerebellum disease dribble palsy is
another one of my lawsuits against the
FDA was spina bifida women who know
about spina bifida or heard of it you
know that folic acid the prenatal bottom
that is one of the things that I forced
the FDA to do to there was three of us
actually that sued the FDA to get folic
acid in prenatal vitamins prevent this
it's a terrible disease totally
unnecessary cripples children when it's
this advanced can occur anywhere along
the spinal cord but eighty percent of
the time it's in a lumbar area
Sammis twins is a nutritional deficiency
the embryo why did they wait so long to
separate these kids s cause they only
ran one liver in between them triplets
but there's only three sets of legs the
two small sets of legs there's no torso
no head no arms and took a series of
surgeries to separate them off safely a
totally preventable congenital deafness
with babies born deaf has nothing to
excite says simple deficiency of a
single mineral we've known that since
1964 but doctors continue to form
institutions to raise money to find the
gene and what I would do is say you know
doctor I would love to donate money to
this fund to find the gene for deafness
but what I want to do before I donate
money I want to see a copy of your taxes
from last year
because I want to see how that money was
distributed that's when they'll say I'm
sorry I can't let you see that wait a
minute you are a publicly you know
you're a public institution I want to
see your tax return no he can't see that
that's because 99% of the money was
donated wound up in his pocket his fees
cleft palate totally preventable
terrible thing to inflict on a kid
because Mama's not getting the 90s sense
of nutrients on your left is a typical
belly button hernia the size of a walnut
easily repaired with the surgery the two
one in the middle one on the right hand
size what would be called gastroschisis
for the stomach and the liver and the
spleen oil intestines are hanging out
these two babies died during the birth
process they should have been delivered
by caesarian section they were perfect
in everybody there was nothing wrong
these baby I was in that they had
bellybutton hernias without skin over
them everything came out during the
forceful contractions during birth and
they died of a stroke where was the
doctor who's supposed to be monitoring
them oh he was in the bathroom giving
himself I'd be drugs
now how many ever heard of thalidomide
so we're old enough remember thalidomide
for 10,000 babies born in America
examples are in the middle and on your
left where the babies were born without
arms and legs are severely deformed our
Moon's and lakes this is because the
mothers were given a drug during
pregnancy for morning sickness called
fluid amide now they had never tested
that drug on pregnant laboratory animals
see if it impacted the embryo 10,000
American families suffer from this the
pharmaceutical company that actually
made the drug paid a couple of million
dollars to the government and fines and
then the families had to suffer by
themselves again had been one of the
occasions where I would have been found
guilty of temporary insanity
right now you're hearing about the Zika
virus have you heard of the Zika virus
okay
these are two babies with microcephaly
the girl on your right is ten years old
her younger sister here is only two
years old
typical faces typical what they look
like because her head is very small
there's forty seven hundred four
thousand seven hundred babies born in
Brazil between June and October of 2015
four thousand seven are babies with this
defect now people are blaming this on a
Zika virus although the same Zika virus
occurs in all or just about all of South
America and Mexico and the Bahamas but
nobody else has seen the same birth
defect so I suspect there's something
else going on there okay there's
something else going on there are they
giving these women a new drug for
morning sickness are they these women
celebrating because it's some holiday
there and they're all out drinking that
part of the pregnancy I don't know
there's something else going on there
because the Zika virus alone is not
going to cause this this gal and you're
right is ten years old before the Zika
virus okay have you ever read some of
the Greek mythology you heard of the
Cyclops terrible warrior with one eye in
the middle of his forehead he his
greatest joy was to hold you and meet
your head you know kind of stuff here's
a kitten with cycloptic
eye here's a sheep my cycloptic eye
here's a shark with cycloptic eye so
when you have two vertebrates from
different families and captain is a
carnivore lamb is a herbivore out there
eating grass and the shark of course as
a fish like critter and they all have
the cycloptic eyesight tells you that
it's not genetic in any way shape or
form it's a simple nutritional
deficiency here's a six-month-old human
baby with Cyclops because mom wasn't
getting those nutrients during pregnancy
some of these kids are strong enough
that they will grow up no in the third
world culture is where they have
villages and they're still
hunter-gatherers when you have a baby
born like this they're usually
suffocated or drowned because it would
be a huge burden because they're barely
making enough living hunting herbs and
food and catching rabbits to survive
with 1012 families in there let alone
have four or five babies with birth
defects so you don't see them in third
world cultures because they're
dispatched if you will when they're born
in animals farm animals and pet animals
reports cycloptic babies one on 16,000
each year because we supplement them so
it's a fairly rare defect in humans is
one in 250 they don't see many of them
because almost all of them are
miscarried almost all miscarriages are
cycloptic babies because they have so
many things going wrong on the inside of
them they don't make it at Yerkes
Institute Emory University in Atlanta
Georgia in 1977 I found the first
non-human case of [__] roses did
biopsies on the other 24 baby monkeys
and that facility did not have any
relationship genetically to that monkey
and they all had since red roses I knew
Amelia was a it was a environmental
thing tracked it down did the
chemistry's figured it out published got
it ready for publication took it to
Emory University the powers would be
rating Memorial Hospital in the rear
Keys primary Center and they fired me
should have been a Nobel Prize but they
fired me well just before they fired me
on the letterhead of experts around the
world they all agreed that my tissues
from this one monkey which I didn't tell
him is a monkey I just said what do you
think this isn't he's a classic example
of cystic fibrosis and so when
originally turned it in Emory University
made a news release hey we're wonderful
and they beat their chests we found the
first non-human cases he proposes we're
gonna have laboratory animals they can
study it and everybody's excited and
then when I did the rest of my research
and found out that it wasn't genetic
past when they fired me that was 1978 in
2005 the scientific journal from the US
Department of Health and Human Services
of the so okay if they came out with
this the International M Trammell
research journal and the federal
government had defunded in June of 2005
primate research had defunded it because
too expensive ten thousand dollars a day
per monkey whereas for Mouse is ten
cents a day and so they said you have to
use mice if you want to use monkeys go
to Warren Buffett or Bill Gates
Foundation
get the money there we're not going to
give it to you this particular issue
they spent the entire issue looking at
primate research projects that benefited
human health over the years so they took
the 20th century as the example the 20th
century and they picked the top 10
research sections in primates top 10
which showed benefit to the humans
number 2 out of the top 10 was my
project on the city versus monkeys back
in 1977 this is 2005 the last sentence
in the part on [__] burrows has said in
brackets Emory University refused to
release the name of the young
pathologist who made the discovery now
why did they put that in there because
they wanted people to know they weren't
that stupid because Emory University had
made a news release it went out of
everywhere every newspaper in the world
had that story when it first came out
every newspaper in the world had this
story well they told these guys if you
put Wallach same in there we're gonna
fire you and so they kind of put their
toes on the free-throw line as far as
they could go and hope somebody else
would follow up on it of course nobody
did but the stories in the book
epigenetics these are the kids you see
with severe paralysis now 1989 I went to
Keyshawn Promise China where I did those
1700 autopsies on kids under the age of
10 the dedication disease which is
cardiomyopathy heart disease that sudden
heart attack death their courage because
of its efficiency of a single mineral
and that deficiency that same mineral is
what causes cirrhosis but deficiency for
that same mineral is what causes most
your district that's not unusual there's
a hundred and forty seven different
diseases that are caused by a calcium
deficiency okay so I went there to do
2000 autopsies on these kids and because
of delays and and political and national
things at hoops I had to jump and so
forth it cost me a week and so I was
only able to do 1,700 instead of 2,000
but I was hoping to find 15 20 30 babies
that had cirrhosis to show that there
was a relationship
well I failed it that I didn't find 20
kids with cirrhosis I found 595 fully
35% I found 100% of those kids that died
also had mustard history and 200 of them
had SIDS sudden infant death syndrome
what was the theory for SIDS ladies well
the baby suffocated cause he's sleeping
on his belly instead of sleeping I was
back no no another group of doctor said
no no they were sleeping on their back
and shouldn't sleep another belly but
none of them looked they didn't do the
special stains to see the damage in the
heart which I did turned out to be SIDS
the same deficiency that causes of
cirrhosis the same deficiency that
causes muster dystrophy oh yeah I found
100 percent of those 1,700 hit muster
dystrophy also 15 years later after
dealing with thousands of Amish kids
because the Amish children have 10 15 20
times more mustard sv and sincere doses
than not Amish families because their
lifestyle is very similar to the
lifestyle of these people in Keshawn
Province China so make a long story
short I picked a hundred of the best
records over 15 years where their
doctors said the baby was cured a
mustard his team gave him to Jerry Lewis
five six six years ago now and he was
excited I said Jerry your these are
Jerry's kids you deserve the right to
make the announcements we have found the
cause for instant cure of monster this
week he took it to the muster dystrophy
association and they fired him that's
why he hasn't done the telethon for the
last five years they should have their
nonprofit standing taken away from them
and all the people were on the board at
that time should be put in jail because
every kid that's barn now with mustard
history our dies from it is on their
head may God forgive them
congestive heart failure deficients have
a single vitamin card amount the heart
disease which we just discussed which is
Keshawn disease deficiency of a single
mineral coronary artery disease is
caused by inflammation microwave popcorn
fried foods processed meats salad
dressings these kinds of things
coronary thrombosis caused by deficiency
but mega-tree is essential fatty acids
cholesterol is not part of the whole
deal there's the evil one microwave
popcorn is one of the reasons why your
children will not live as long as your
you I'll show you the the front-page
news story in a moment where this was in
their fifty thousand heart attacks a
year and kids and twenty thousand of
them died from microwave popcorn
remember I told you earlier that
cholesterol and saturated fat doesn't
cause coronary artery disease it's
inflammation from eating trans fats and
hero cycling means the demonization of
cholesterol and saturated fat saying
that they were the cause of blocked
arteries and heart attacks and so forth
was to sell a new product at Procter &
Gamble wanted to sell in 1952 called
Crisco so Procter and Gamble
through the efforts of a medical doctor
who was a professor of medicine the
university Minnesota he was also on the
board of Procter & Gamble he was also
aboard American Heart Association and he
brokered the deal were were Procter &
Gamble gave the American Heart
Association back in 1952 1.7 million
dollars to endorse Crisco is a healthier
way to eat than lard cream and butter
there's no science to show that but they
took the 1.7 million dollars in endorsed
Crisco
oh I have to tell you Chris Joe started
out in 1901 the German Navy went to a
German chemist by the name of Wilhelm
Norman said look we need a smokeless
synthetic diesel submarine lubricant and
four years later in 1904 he came up with
what we now call Crisco after this first
world war they didn't need it anymore so
they sold the patent to a soap
manufacturing company in England which
owned it until after the Second World
War and they couldn't sell very much
soap because everybody's making their
own soap then after the Second World War
Procter & Gamble bought it through
through again the efforts of Ancel keys
that medical doctor and they gave the
American Heart Association 1.7 million
dollars to demonize cholesterol
saturated lard cream eggs and butter so
they could sell Crisco now I looked for
35 years to find the paper there was a
pivotal paper showing that saturated fat
and Crisco caused heart disease in an
artery disease couldn't find it and then
about three years ago now a billionaire
who I'm helped with his health I was up
in Canada he shipped me a copy that Wall
Street Journal was a to full page
article on the story of how Procter &
Gamble paid the American Heart
Association 1.7 million dollars to
demonize cluster on central fat so they
can sell Crisco
and they weren't selling much even
though the American Heart Association
endorsed Crisco they couldn't sell much
still because it wasn't very romantic or
sexy
so Keyes decided to come up with a a
program that made it more sexy to eat
Crisco and he came up with the
Mediterranean diet
metrand out was never a study it was
always just a sales campaign to sell
Crisco get over it
there's Keshawn China and of course in
September see me in January in January
of 2015
another one of our lawsuits with the FDA
we got selenium and being approved to
put into infant farm loose sometime the
next couple of days I want you to go buy
a pharmacy or go buy a grocery store and
look at infant formula cat the analyses
label on the infant farm on the
ingredients label there's gonna be three
to five minerals in there we need 60
where's the baby gonna get the other 57
to 55 unless you supplement them you're
gonna be burying them is what it comes
down to well we got selenium to be able
to be put in there now so in the next
couple of months they should be adding
the selenium remember SIDS is caused by
a deficiency of this mineral most jiske
is caused by deficiency this mineral
cardiomyopathy heart disease is caused
by divisions in this mineral and also
assistir it broseph's these are the
Chinese kids
Keshawn provinces that red province up
in the upper right hand corner kind of
like New England and China mainland
China red current professor medicine
University of Colorado normal plasma
cholesterol an 8 year old man he's 25
eggs a day came out March of 1991 in New
England Journal of Medicine a
publication from Harvard Medical School
and he's examining this guy showing
newly graduated doctors how to examine a
senior and he says wait a minute you're
all your blood says Sara says you're in
you're 50 and you look like you're 50
and then your birthday it says you're a
TA is this you he said yeah that's me
says everybody says that what do you
attribute your youthful looks to in your
health which we can document according
to the bloodwork he says well he stood
up and he threw his shoulders back and
puffed his chest I said I ate 25 eggs a
day of course that mortified the doctor
that's not what he wanted these students
to hear and he says ok sir I can see him
Fanning himself that wasn't in the
report but I can see him Fanning himself
with a clipboard very nervous he said ok
why does he eat 25 eggs a day and he
said that's because it made me more
studly
what you think about this testosterone
estrogen progesterone adrenal hormones
are for steroid hormones they're 95% by
weight cholesterol so you go on a
cholesterol strict diet you take statin
drugs lower your cholesterol
there ain't nobody home anymore
now the pharmacy industry the
pharmaceutical industry loved that they
came out with Viagra and Cialis and now
they got women's viagra they're having
the time of their lives and of course
they're pumping out statin drugs as much
as they can to get you in that situation
they're burn the candle they're burning
your candle at both ends so to speak
these three Time magazine covers gives
you the whole story of cholesterol
there's a picture in 1961 of Ancel keys
the guy who brokered the deal between
Procter & Gamble the American Heart
Association was at 1.7 million dollars
he was considered the savior of the
American cardiovascular system because
he pointed out for the first time the
cholesterol was a demon and he looks
like an OPS he doesn't he in the Time
magazine cover 1984 again demonizing
cholesterol was a paid ad then 2014
cover article Time magazine eat butter
why scientists labeled saturated fat the
enemy and why they were wrong was a
five-page story on Ancel keys and how he
brokered the deal for 1.7 million
dollars to get the American Heart
Association to endorse Crisco without
one scientific article on it the culture
on earth that has the fewest card of a
service they have no heart attacks no
strokes or the Inuit Eskimos above the
Antarctic Circle they actually live on
nothing but whale meat and whale blubber
Walters mean walrus blubber seal meat
and seal blubber bear mean bear fat they
don't eat fruit they don't eat
vegetables they don't eat nuts they
don't eat grain their cholesterol is
running 350 to 500 this has been
reported at least 25 times a year for
the last 1215 years if doctors don't pay
attention to this they're the ones that
came up with the concept of sit around
the fire and chew the fat see they're
all eating raw whale fat right here
now the only time they're going to get a
heart attack or stroke is if they come
to New Jersey and eat like you Pam
you're good salt is not bad in fact salt
has two very very very essential
nutrients sodium and chloride and
doctors and their ignorance have
demonized again sodium and chloride
they're both the essential nutrients and
any doctor who tells you you need to
restrict so you got high blood pressure
you should immediately get up walk out
go home and on the internet fire them
immediately because they have shortened
your life by about 25 years if you get
on a salt restricted diet 1982 salt a
new villain 2014 salt doesn't cause high
blood pressure I said that in 71 in some
of my publications science news very
famous very well-respected scientific
journal the lead article in June of 2012
good cholesterol not beneficial wait a
minute my doctor says is everything the
subtitle was higher HDL high density
lipoprotein good cholesterol high good
cholesterol levels don't reduce heart
attacks you know why
congestive heart failure is caused by
deficiency of a single vitamin clear
mouthy heart disease is a deficiency of
a single mineral coronary artery disease
is caused by inflammation eating fried
foods processed meats oils gluten
microwave popcorn Lakan stuff and then
thrombotic stroke and coronary
thrombosis we get a blood clot in a
coronary artery is caused by not closed
from saturated fat but a deficiency
omega-3s are a racial pump between
omega-3 sixes and nines this is what
kills your kids they come home from
school they're Dunkin their Oreo cookies
and some zero fat milk and or maybe even
rice milk or soy milk which is has no
relationship nutritionally in the milk
whatsoever we should be against the law
for them to call those things milk the
white icing in there is nothing but
margin that hasn't been dyed yellow is
just nothing but trans fats and
heterocyclic amines and acrylamide cause
inflammation plug the arteries and cause
many many other diseases and of course
margin is the worst type of fat for the
herb well my doctor says I have to use
Marg instead of butter remember that's
why they lived to be 50
okay now this is where we got that
statistic which said that that microwave
popcorn and theater popcorn causes
50,000 heart attacks and kids every year
in America and 20,000 deaths in kids we
sent them a note saying look we're gonna
sue you for the tenth time now and this
is on trans fats it's been long enough
you need to get this stuff out of the
food that was in January of 2015 when we
got that nod from the FDA that we could
demand that legally that they put two
slain him into baby formulas okay we're
going on to the 10th lawsuit now the FDA
six months later in June of 2015 said
the FDA is now to trim trans fats out of
food well that's not good enough
they should have done it immediately you
have 30 days to get trans fat out of
your product or we're taking your
product off the market but they're gonna
give them a grace period of six months
or a year whatever it is and so I feel
that that's okay because there's no
statute of limitations on murder is
there now raise your hand if you've
heard that exercise is good for you you
don't raise your ember this is a house
of God
whether you believe it or not have you
heard that exercise good for you okay
that's better that's better okay what
turns out if you take all professional
athletes from all sports and combine the
data the average lifespan is 62 except
for football players is 51 professional
footballer is 51
that's according to insurance actuaries
and there's never been a professional
athlete ever live to be 100
now the top professional athletes they
make 5 6 8 10 million dollars a game the
top athletes get pampers they get
massages ten times a day they get the
best food to get the best personal
trainers I mean I mean it'd be like you
ladies who your whole life is around
knitting you just love it in it I mean
grab some grandma that's it their whole
life they want to knit for all their
grandkids and great-grandkids and then
you never see them without their
knitting needs man they're just going at
it right what have you got paid five
million dollars every Saturday when
you're knitting for knitting would that
be cool I mean what a great profession
and yet there's never been a
professional athlete ever lived to be a
hundred some of those you know of Jim
Fixx
top runner in fact he was a professor of
economics and one of the Ivy League
colleges up here I don't remember which
one he died a fifty-two of
cardiomyopathy heart attack a deficient
at one minute while he was running his
protege Brian Maxwell from Canada had 12
gold medals in long-distance running
he invented the power bar nestles gave
him 300 million dollars for the rights
of power bar and then three months later
he died while he was running at age 51
of a cardiomyopathy a heart attack he's
not a fitness guru anymore he's just goo
Reggie Lewis 28 years old captain of the
Boston Celtics collapsed during a
playoff game of the Charlotte Hornets
way back then 1994 I believe it was and
he survived and and the top cardiologist
in America is a cardiologist for the
astronauts and NASA he was the head of
the department of cardiology at Harvard
Medical School
gave him a minimum exercise regimen he
could just stand at the free-throw line
and throw free throws and he put him on
like six different drugs for his
cardiomyopathy heart disease and to
excel ater he died from the second come
out of a heart attack because nobody
gave him two cents worth of selenium
here's that cardiologist dr. W Thomas
ness I ran the Boston Marathon 20 times
he was considered the world's top
cardiologist and he dies in Accardi mapa
the heart disease a year and a half
after Reggie did at age 48 his 16 year
old kid in the left West Leonard
Fennville Michigan a semi finals playoff
sudden-death when he got the points his
four teammates from the court are
lifting him up in front of 10,000
cheering local fans and he dies in their
arms of a cardiomyopathy a heart attack
the County examiner medical examiner who
did the autopsy on him says we don't
know why he died of this heart attack it
could have been the stresses of sports
now that guy should go to jail because
every time a kid dies from this is
because he didn't say it was caused by
deficiency of selenium he should go to
jail for that the girl on your right
Rennell to pierce was a freshman at
Florida State University she dropped
dead a ruptured aneurysm while in the
middle of a game 19 years old and the
doctor said she had a genetic disease
called Kawasaki's disease babies are
born with aneurysms and they died within
a couple of months of a ruptured
aneurysm and this is thought to be a
genetic disease because babies are born
with this this goes back to the days of
what Darwin write in the 1800s it's
actually a nutritional deficiency of a
single mineral a single mineral
deficiency results in a breakdown of the
elastic fibers in your blood vessels you
can get spider veins varicose veins
hemorrhoids and and
from a deficiency that mineral and it
wasn't a genetic disease in a girl she
just had a deficiency because she's
drinking one of the other sports drinks
Gatorade has two nutrients not that one
Powerade has six nutrients not that one
so these are kids top ten obituaries in
the first couple of months of this year
in the first couple months of last year
these are all kids that died under the
age of 15 from quite a mouth the heart
attacks right here in America girls
cheerleaders softball players peewee
leagues this is just ten of them 20,000
of these kids die every year in America
I'm a cardiomyopathy heart attack or
ruptured aneurysms because nobody's told
their parents or grandparents that they
need the 90 essential nutrients somebody
needs to go to jail a hockey player is
16 years old
dr. Carter mapped the heart disease the
doctors up in Canada said they still
don't know the cause of his death here's
some of your favorite professional
athletes
I love this one I mean he is one
mean-looking dude look at that look at
his six-pack look at the biceps I mean
his biceps were bigger than
schwarzenegger x' and he died of a
deficiency of a single mineral BAM he
was dead
this one this fella here was a
cardiologist and also professional
soccer player in Brazil and he died
during a soccer game at age 57 so what's
going on here
athletes whether you're professional
athlete or not sweat no drink a lot of
water to rehydrate which is not a bad
thing but sweat is not water sweat is a
soup that contains all the nutrients
floating around your blood let's say
you're not supplementing you have 6575
nutrients floating around in there and
you're just drinking water you'll get a
breakdown in your tendons and ligaments
you'll have muscle tears your discs will
blow out you'll collapse during a game
and die
you take the 90 essential nutrients now
that'll ever happen because you'll be
replacing what you sweat out so we came
up with rebound
remember Gatorade has two nutrients
power he has six our rebound has 100
including the selenium and the mineral
is missing when you get ruptured
aneurysms okay now this is Theo Ratliff
from Atlanta Georgia he's playing with
the Hawks had you know 28 years old had
bone to bone or I suppose knees that
cartilage popped off his right hip he
broke his wrist catching a pass from a
teammate during a regulation game then
the doctors of the Atlanta Hawks had
looked this guy's too fragile play ball
he took his contract away from him and
young introduced me to him we rebuilt
him in 90 days he got his position back
he played for 14 more years he made a
hundred and forty million dollars using
our rebound because we were replacing
everything that he was sweating out and
his wife Christina loves me
now we're gonna change subjects here a
little bit but very very very important
subject this is in the news all right
now this is one of the fastest-growing
problems in the United States because
there's more and more young kids who are
gay or lesbian or bisexual transgender
asexual and this is not a choice this is
a congenital event I'll call it's a
congenital event mom is missing
something at the time when the preoptic
hypothalamus the brain is farm there's
two things that happen when the sperm
fertilizes the egg instantly you're
either gonna be an xx female or XY male
genetically but the preoptic
hypothalamus your brain goes off in a
different direction it might take you
know seven weeks the third to seventh
week of pregnancy which is three to
seven weeks after you were determined
structurally to be a boy or a girl
physiologically to be a boy or girl but
who you receive signals from who you
give signals to is determined by that
part of the brain which develops three
to seven weeks later this is not a
choice this is a this is a congenital
event I don't to use the word birth
defect but it's a congenital event the
same principle as a birth defect when
you look at the holy books the Old
Testament the New Testament the Quran
you look at the holy books for the
Hindus and the holy books for the Shin
twos in Japan all these holy books talk
about two categories of disease one is
infectious diseases epidemics plagues
leprosy and they always talk about
homosexuality all of them talk about
homosexuality none of them talk about
Down syndrome now to talk about cleft
palate not even talk about cerebal
palsey which are very easy thing you
don't even know what it is but you can
describe it back in those days three
thousand five thousand years ago
generals and rich wealthy merchants and
kings and Pharaohs used to collect
babies with birth defects they would
send their soldiers out to give the
villagers some money to get the baby
with a birth defect they called them
monsters in those days like the kids
that are just horribly deformed okay and
they would drown them or suffocate
and they put in bottles of alcohol some
of these collections have 30,000 50,000
infants in them and over the years the
families gave them to the medical
museums of Europe in the United States
in the book epigenetics I give you the
names of the museum's and the names of
the collections that are in there so you
can go look at them if you want so we
know those birth defects happened back
then those physical birth defects
happened back then but the holy books
only talked about homosexuality and
infectious diseases and this is what's
going on at this time okay June 2014
cover story on transgenders now this is
a white-tailed deer from upstate New
York
anybody here ever go hunting not many
okay for you over here
all right well white-tailed deer are
very interesting they're a common deer
cross North America and this was an
upstate New York during hunting season
this fella sees what's a record set of
antlers I mean he knows this is boone
and crockett this is a record set of
antlers and if we open sights he shoots
the deer goes up to dress it to cut it
open and take all the guts out you
realize this is a girl this female deers
don't have antlers this is the
equivalent of a bearded lady in a circus
and in that same area where those
transgender deer are they have the
highest rate of transgender humans in
America because the food that they're
eating from that same soil up there is
deficient in these nutrients there's
1,500 species of vertebrates including
African animals free-ranging African
animals zoo animals from all over the
world 1,500 domestic animals pet animals
that have been documented to have
transgender behavior gay and lesbian
behavior you know Sonny cher Bono they
had chastity became chaste and then
there was Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt
has Shiloh who became John and those are
common things right now there's seven
hundred thousand registered transgender
in America there's fifty thousand
transgenders serving with honor and our
military now this fella here on your
left dr. Richard Raskind
it was a very famous eye surgeon who
invented the laser surgery to tack down
torn retina so didn't have to cut the
eyeball open he also was the top-ranked
tennis player amateur tennis player in
the world
his last child reached 18 years of age
35 years ago this is 35 years ago last
child reached 18 years of age he went to
Denver and became renee Richards 35
years before Bruce Jenner became Caitlyn
but the thing that made this a big story
that went on for a couple of years was
it
renee Richards wanted to keep the top
ranking in the tennis amateur tennis
thing as a girl when it transferred from
the boy to the girl and in the end the
Supreme Court awarded renee Richards the
title then of course you know the story
of Bruce Jenner you need to read Vanity
Fair if you haven't read it there's 25
pages it's essentially his biography and
he knew and he was a little kid when
he's true 3 years old that he would
rather be a girl than a boy but he had
all the physical equipment of a boy and
so he worked real hard and and pushups
and running and walking and chin-ups and
all this kind of stuff to be as strong
as he could and he'd run and run and run
he won all these medals and he lettered
in university and many sports because
structurally and physically he was a boy
but in his preoptic hypothalamus he was
a girl because mother didn't eat the
right things and didn't get the right
things during that part of the pregnancy
of course this pink pinwheel in the
middle of the brain there that's the
part that little peninsula hanging down
the size your little finger is the pre
optic hypothalamus they're supposed to
be 450 cells in there by actual count to
be a heterosexual there's no cells in
there and this happens many times no
cells in there guess what you're you're
a asexual person crazy aunt Ruthy who
never would get in a car alone with a
boy she would be the one to wash all
your clothes and babysit your kids and
on vacation she everybody loved her
she's the best cook in the family she'd
send out all your Christmas cards for
and lick all the stamps but don't get
her near a boy and then there's crazy
uncle Frank who never would sit in a car
with a girl all you want to do is rotate
your
tires and work on your carburetor mow
your lawn heck sort of stuff trim your
trees weed your garden but he did not
want to be around girls those are
asexual people they have no cells in
that part of the brain and then you have
say 200 cells in the brain and 100 cells
say chase boys 100 cells chase girls
you're bisexual let's say those 200
cells they all land on the side that say
chase girls and you're an XY boys
genetically and chase girls you're a
girl crazy that's good but if your girl
xx and it says chase girls your lesbian
now let's say all those 200 cells fall
on the side that says chase boys if
you're a girl you're an xx girl you
chase boys that your boy crazy that's a
good thing but if your boy and your XY
genetically and this part of your brain
says chase boys you're gay then if you
have your 450 cells you're straight
you're heterosexual so we're in command
of this after the fact it can't be
reversed now there may be some time when
we can genetically engineer cells and
put the right cells in the right place
and change things but right now we don't
have technology but it's totally
preventable
okay this is that June 15th
Time magazine senator folding these kids
are all cousins the mothers are sisters
from the same grandmother one mother is
the mother of the two children that have
the pink outfits the second sister is
the mother of the child the yellow
outfit
the third mother all three sisters is a
mother of the child with the blue outfit
all the boys are fishing in the farm
pond these four kids are picking flowers
and tripping through the meadow singing
little girly songs obviously by looking
at the one in the blue on your right
physically is a boy XY but in his brain
and his preoptic hypothalamus he's a
girl we already talked about obesity
being a deficiency of a single category
and nutrients experts say 70% of our
kids under the age of 12 are overweight
40% of our kids in the age of 12 are
obese 35 pounds of overweight and it has
nothing to do with eating too much or
lack of exercise this little girl here
Natalie Hayhurst from Terre Haute
Indiana has the same deficiencies but
she didn't gain any weight because her
mother was kind of a anti fat anti soda
freak had nothing in the house would
make you gain weight so she ate
lightbulbs she was on the news all the
time of course she ate lipo there's no
calories in lightbulbs so she ate weird
things but she didn't gain any weight
cuz there's no calories night bones
malabsorption can be a cause of OBC
because even if you supplement with
those nutrients you can't absorb them
you're gonna gain weight cuz the symptom
of a deficiency in these nutrients is
the munchies now this is Newark New
Jersey in 1920 these girls were told
that exercise is going to help them lose
weight while they're having a lot of fun
and some sisterhood stuff there but
guess what they're gonna be disappointed
Loyola University School of Medicine
Chicago January 2009 they did a ten year
study exercise will not make you lose
weight eight months later in August of
2009 cover article Time magazine the
myth about exercise it won't make you
lose weight okay and pastor you may know
this individual I haven't led better
from Charlotte North Carolina
I met him almost four years ago now he
weighed 423 pounds he's in the picture
on the left in the pink shirt and on our
program he lost 17 pounds in the first
week first time in his whole life he
never lost any weight
we added what we call ASAP it's a kind
of an accelerator that's an acronym for
as slim as possible as soon as possible
and he lost 60 pounds in the first 30
days two pounds a day went from 400
pounds and then in seven months he
dropped down to 165 and then the right
hand picture he is the one looking at
you over his right shoulder same guy
that weighed 400 pound 4 and 23 pounds
when I met him he has not gained a half
ounce back because he stayed in the 19th
century it's a simple nutritional
deficiency and it's not unusual to lose
a half a pound of 2 pounds a day and
some people need to lose more than 100
pounds I see people who are 400 600 800
pounds they'll lose 4 pounds a day they
never have to have any surgery because
they're getting all the nutrients and
the skin tightens up as they lose the
weight and they never have to have any
surgery for loose skin now this is a
horse born an Amish horse and buggy
Amish horse farm in Adams County Indiana
just south of Fort Wayne Indiana and I
was there to see mustards feed kids but
they were late and so being a
veterinarian and a physician I went into
the barn to look around the animals and
this is called cribbing in animals
called munchies and people
and we choose rather neat the furniture
we choose to eat something that could
cause us to gain weight osteoarthritis
is a simple deficiency of vitamins and
minerals has nothing with age or
genetics it is repairable you can
actually give your body the raw
materials to support and promote
maintenance the repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebra bone make
supona cell unless you've been run over
by a tank nobody ever needs to get a
joint replacement I'm gonna repeat that
unless you get run over by a tank nobody
ever has to get a joint replacement so
why would them what a doctor once you
get joint replacement because he makes
$2,500 every time he does it
Cole is linked to bone brakes because
you're getting a lot of phosphorus in
the cola which replaced the cocaine and
this phosphorus messes up the calcium
phosphate ratio and this way you have a
lot of young athletes to get fractures
you get a lot of middle-aged people who
do hard physical work at fractures
because you're drinking soft drinks
calcium deficiency causes kidney stones
every one of them there's no exception
you go to your algae's you have a kidney
stone easy oh my god you got to get rid
of dairy out of your life and even if
you're on supplements account you got to
stop that we got to get all the calcium
out of your life here
your blood calcium is too high and
you're getting kidney stones no just the
opposite you need to take more calcium
your blood calcium will come down you
won't get any more kidney stones
paparazzi posted drugs are pulled off
the market
pazzo maxwell phosphate phosphorus too
much phosphorus that was a dumb idea on
their part another failed medical theory
and they wanted you to believe ladies
that women got osteoporosis when they
went through menopause because they
didn't have enough estrogen raise your
hand ladies have you ever heard that one
well you were duped on that one men get
osteoporosis more frequently and more
severely than women now that was a
failed medical theory because little
girls got osteoporosis when little girls
get osteoporosis they call it
osteomalacia and kids this is how she
approached this and kids go I'll
simulation gave it a different name
because a different age group you take
the 90 essential nutrients with some
secret sauce to rebuild the the not only
the rebar in the bone but also help you
put
more minerals in your bones and I don't
care if you have osteopenia osteoporosis
osteoarthritis you generalize bone MRIs
rheumatoid arthritis bone to bone
arthritis kidney stones you have a
history of bone spurs calcium deposits
periodontal disease it's all nutritional
deficiencies particularly calcium and
vitamin d3 and and some of the like Oh
strontium is another one you need to
have to prevent fractures and so on and
so you need a program we have the 90
essential nutrients plus what we call
the secret sauce or to talk about during
the qat
this is Andy Young Zim living room in
1991 I was there because I had written
so many articles on how to prevent
sickle cell anemia and how to address it
better and make it better for people
more efficiently than drugs and so he
called me from from California to
Atlanta this is a living room and I
noticed he was limping I said with all
due respects mr. ambassador why are you
limping he said well I got bone to bone
or thright us and both knees I'm
scheduled in two weeks to have a double
knee replacement I said sir with all due
respects give me 90 days cancel your
surgery delay it give me 90 days and I
can rebuild that for it without surgery
because I'm going to Emory University
I'm going to great Memorial Hospital the
best doctors in the world where they're
the ones that fired me over the Cystic
Fibrosis saying it's why I let him have
an earful of that and then he canceled
the surgery nice I'll give you 90 days
90 days I rebuilt him and he introduced
me to a lot of people after that we
still do a lot of things together okay
he introduced me to Lisa Jones who was
on that women's basketball team America
for the Olympics that won all the gold
medals and she's training for the third
Olympics and she's 40 years old in this
picture and rebuilt her hamstring
rebuilt her Achilles tendon the surgeons
who put her back together said look
you're not going to play for the same
skill over you might think of coaching
rather than playing she got her position
back she got her third gold medal and
this is us on stage in California I'm
giving her a certificate saying she's an
ambassador for women athletes for
youngevity company well they allowed me
to ask you one question said delecia
I've got to ask you one question I'm
allowed to ask you one question this has
been since I've met you you know a
couple of years ago
has been really I have to know the
answer this ratio okay doc whatever you
want now we're in front of 3,000 people
I said delecia I have to know why does a
woman who's six foot five were eight
inch heels
as she said well doc is simple it makes
you more sexy this is a Harvard Medical
School that was published in New England
Journal of Medicine abstracted in
newspapers these search for arthritis is
worthless they looked at the records at
300,000 people who had knee replacement
surgeries and hip replacement surgery
and they found out that this knee
replacement surgery for arthritis is
worthless because the bone contingent
deteriorate doesn't stop the problem and
so that's where Andy Young of course
this came out after I had talked with
him okay I had talked to him in 1991 and
here at came and say see you master
we're way ahead of ya you're right okay
so even heard Medical School now agrees
with me give me 90 days before you have
any joints replace okay you won't get
the surgery same thing with the back
four years later they looked at the same
300 thousand records but this time they
looked at the back and they looked at
the the discs in between the vertebrae
and peripheral neuropathies and sciatica
and lower back pain do not get surgery
give me 90 days first and doing God's
thing guess what you won't need the
surgery thank you
type two diabetes now
the Pima Indians are worth five minutes
here or less three to five minutes the
Pima Indians their their range where
they live spreads from Arizona in the
southern southwestern part of United
States Arizona and you can look and you
can see that line which is the border of
United States and Mexico going
underneath the eye and then through the
middle of the pea under Pima that little
bit of yellow above the line there is
10% of the Pima Indian populations above
the line in Arizona and 90% of the Pima
Indians down in the yellow below which
makes them about a third of the western
part of the mainland of Mexico okay
they're all the same team pool they're
the only Native Americans who never
mixed with anybody else
every other Native American tribe makes
other Native Americans they mixed with
the slaves when they were freed after
emancipation because they wanted the
skills in farming and Industry and so
forth but the Pima Indians are the only
ones who didn't even mess around with
the Explorers okay they're perfect 170
million genes the ones are left here the
Mexican Pima Indians are kind of like
the Amish they don't participate in
anything we think of as being first
world there's sort of subsistence
farmers and they're on the side of the
road here selling jars if they make out
of pottery pottery jars and things they
don't have vehicles no roads they they
go everywhere on horseback or walk they
use horses to plow these horses pull
wagons they have no utilities no doctors
I mean they just sort of say to
themselves okay these are the Mexican PM
unions that's below the line they make
up 90% of the population of Pima Indians
above the line 10% of the Pima Indians
in America in Arizona they work in the
RV assembly factories in Arizona they're
all obese including the kids they all
have a car a van a pickup truck all use
doctors now let's have a look let's look
at the Mexican Mexican Pima Indians the
diabetes rate type two diabetes rate
they have the lowest rate of diabetes
the entire world six percent or less
let's look at the Pima Indians
above the border in Arizona BAM
46% they have the highest rate you have
the highest rate of diabetes of anywhere
in the world same genetics same genetics
of core this mystifies doctors but I'm
going to show you why in just a few
moments the cases of type 2 diabetes are
doubling every year now it's going in a
in a geometric proportions
three-year-old babies are now weighs
seventy seven pounds they weigh as much
as ten year olds more blacks lose legs
to diabetes and whites that's not
because it's a genetic thing that's
because the black community's enslaved
by the medical community remember the
story that critics Scott King told me
and these are the things that dr. King
was going against because they say the
outrageous things that doctors do to the
black population pale the Tuskegee
experiments when you read that book
epigenetics you will cry cancers are
self-inflicted disease it is not genetic
in any way shape or form all the studies
on chemotherapy cannot be duplicated
because none of it's true
the FDA relies on research done by the
pharmaceutical companies that makes it
they don't say we're going to do an
experiment and see if we can come up
with the same results before we approve
it they just approve it based on what
the companies tell them 1971 I said
genex has nothing to do with cancer it
has to do with trans-fats hitter cyclic
means acrylamide inflammation from
eating things like deli slices sandwich
meats sausage ham bacon Bologna salami
pastrami pepperoni jerky car B spam and
everybody laughed at me in 1971 well
here the world hell
organization came out in October 2015
not the FDA not any Medical Association
of any state or nationally the World
Health Organization came out they called
me from England and they told me doc
where do you see your newspapers on
Monday the World Health Organization's
agreeing with you what you said in 71
the World Health Organization now says
that eating these types of processed
meats are as great a threat or greater
for trading cancer as smoking two packs
of cigarettes today are working in an
asbestos environment you will be burying
your children if you let him eat that
stuff
and so Time magazine says report links
meat with cancer that's not true
it's processed meats all 20 the top
longevity cultures in the world
according to National Geographic and
Pasteur if it's okay I'm gonna go to
12:30 is that okay okay
our meat-eaters there's not a single
vegetarian or vegan bunch of the top 20
longevity groups or cultures according
to the National Geographic not me
I'm just reporting what they say so
let's get rid of this they're never
gonna find a cure for cancer looking
where they're looking because they're
looking at genetics oh I went too fast
it's gonna kind of do this let me share
with you that you can prevent cancer in
your family very simple don't eat into
the bad stuff take all the 90 essential
nutrients give just be like that baby
Huey group give your body everything it
needs to maximize your defenses against
horrible diseases this was the first
attempt at at a prevention for
universities got together and gave
people who they felt were high risk of
having cancer long term study they gave
them 200 micrograms of selenium about a
fifth of a milligram very small amount
they couldn't get it published in
medical journals even though it showed
that you could reduce your risk of colon
cancer by 95% by supplementing with
selenium your risk of prostate cancer
guys by 69% reduce your risk of breast
cancer ladies depending on whose daddy
looked at anywhere from 32 to 82% and
the medical journals didn't want to
publish it so they got it published in
Popular Mechanics magazine
of 1912 well in 1998 the University of
Arizona did the same study the same
number people got exactly the same
result got it published in annals of
Medicine which is a very famous medical
journal now high fiber diets don't cut
colon cancer that's a failed theory this
particular thing this is a Harvard
Nurses Health Study 90,000 nurses over
20 years the University of South
Carolina was given the piece to look at
how the percentages of breast cancer
diagnosis varied depending on how women
cooked their food they particularly
looked at how women cook their meat they
found out and this is published they
said if you cook your meat very
well-done where the fat is brown or
burnt increase your risk of breast
cancer ladies by four hundred and sixty
two percent which means you're going to
get it the figure is in the last Oh see
the third sentence from the bottom in
the second from the right column there
says four hundred sixty two percent
increase in breast cancer if you cook
your meat well-done if you cook your
meat medium-rare reduce your risk of
breast cancer by four hundred and sixty
two percent that's a nine hundred point
difference between your going to get it
and you don't have to have it ladies
never never never never eat anything
cooked well done ok again mammograms
let's say for every hundreds that are
found to be positive mammograms do you
say oh you got a highly suspicious thing
you probably have breast cancer
61% are false positives but doctors are
gonna run you through the biopsies and
chemotherapy and radiation remove your
breast and when they send your breast
they just amputated to the lab they say
well if she didn't have breast cancer
oh no let's go have a martini
everything's fine there's my favorite
highway billboard hot dogs cause but
cancer
I'm about sixes these in the Beltway
around Chicago and they're talking
directly to little kids because what
does grandma feed the kid on the weekend
and microwave popcorn and Oreo cookies
BAM they're dead
Jane eggs have nothing to do with cancer
arsenic which we known to be an
essential nutrient since 1947 in one
type of leukemia acute promyelocytic
leukemia which kills you in six months
they did a big study this is a
University of New York City big study
and after 10 years is large group of
people who had to keep promyelocytic
leukemia they're still in remission now
wait a minute this is supposed to kill
them in six months they quit the
experiment he said well this is go on
forever these kid people are not going
to die now do you think that they said
hey we found a cure for acute
promyelocytic leukemia no well sort of
the rogue the rebel medical doctors are
saying it looks like arsenic deficiency
causes leukemia dementia remember Alison
Rosie's is a physician cause disease
seventy-five percent of your brain
weight is the myelin the white matter of
the brain which is at 75 percent of your
brain weight the myelin is in fact 100
percent cholesterol when it goes away
because you're taking
cholesterol-lowering drugs you're eating
egg beaters instead of eggs you're using
margarine instead of butter you're using
lots of salad dressing because some
hippies said it was good for you you're
gonna get alzheimers disease say
physician cause disease faster dementia
that's cause the blood vessels in your
brain or plug from the same thing to
plug your arteries in your heart
Korsakoff syndrome is a deficiency of a
single vitamin Warnecke korsakoff's is a
deficient that vitamin + ms mixed in
there with it i made 12 deficiency
dementia is self-explanatory Hillary
said Alzheimers is an irreversible
progressive brain disorder with no known
cause for venture cure I will spend 2
billion dollars a year of your tax money
to find a cure well in actuality you can
prevent it by 78% right
no double-blind randomized study by
Johns Hopkins you guys ever hear Johns
Hopkins your kind of neighbors are those
guys right Baltimore Maryland very
well-respected medical school they did
the research on five thousand people ten
years half of them twenty five hundred
got a supplement 2500 you haven't got a
dummy pill and the ones that had the
supplement guess what has 78 percent
less after ten years had 70% less
al-harazi's this is my favorite
Alzheimers story in the newspaper
mother and son share the bonds of love
and Alison Rosie's he's 52 years old he
has Alzheimer's disease as his mother of
82 she has Al's her disease they're both
on the same statin drugs to lower
cholesterol they're both in the same
facility nursing home their doctors are
the same guy who wrote them both the
same prescriptions for santen drugs and
he owns the nursing home somebody needs
to go to jail what would happen to a
politician what would happen to the
mayor of your city would give all of the
contracts for construction and
maintenance and work to his
brother-in-law without throwing out a
bid you didn't teach him wouldn't you
he'd be out right away but doctors get
away with this all the time this is what
made my audio cassette tape in 1991 so
controversial vitamin E can ease memory
loss Allison his patients you can take
someone who's advanced Allison disease
came a large dose of vitamin E within
three months he'll be able to find their
way back home you take them around the
block spin them around they can find the
way back home they can cook simple meals
and dress themselves or before they just
sit there like a vegetable just with one
vitamin this is a news release on this
story from Johns Hopkins it started two
years later after that study on vitamin
E which was published in 1992 two years
later in 1994 Johns Hopkins set up this
experiment and they just added vitamin C
to the vitamin E said well maybe we can
maybe we can actually prevent it now
these people were all the same same
religion they ate the same way they
avoided the same food they're all
farmers in the same Valley so it was
about as good of a double-blind
randomized studies
getting human beings he's not like
sixteen different professions different
cities and all that kind of stuff right
okay this is why we have things that are
generational in families it's not
genetic gluten intolerance well
t-mobile okay celiac disease busted
celiac disease appendicitis
diverticulitis your bowel syndrome
inflammatory bowel disease colitis ulcer
colitis Crohn's disease asthma
bronchitis other respiratory almost like
pneumonia a winter eczema rosacea
dermatitis psoriasis infertility
miscarriages if you have any one of
these things you don't need to go any
further your you have a gluten
intolerance gluten intolerance causes
all these things because these are all
caused by nutritional deficiencies now
there's 900 different nutritional
deficiency diseases you can get all of
them you have gluten intolerance and
here's why on your left on that a is a
cut through the small intestine of a
healthy one-year-old rat you can see the
finger-like villi increases the
absorptive surface your intestines by
95% on the middle photomicrographs see
there you can see where they've lost 50%
of those villi look at all the scar
tissue in there they were on a gluten
high gluten diet for six months the ones
on your right in an e we're on a high
gluten diet for a year 95% of those
villi are gone look at all that scar
tissue how do you get vitamins and
minerals through that stuff you can't
your gluten-free diet for kids under the
age of 10 and very rapidly about two to
four weeks you're gonna see a magic
thing it's a god thing I mean just like
pastor creflo dollar's daughter and two
weeks time she was cured we put on a
gluten-free diet as well as supplemented
her her intestines healed not at all it
might take you six to eight weeks before
you see something dramatic it might take
two or three months for a kid under the
age of 10 to go from E where you're 95%
is scarred up back to a normal healthy
intestine our age 50 60 70 80 years of
age it might take you a year to get
totally healed but you'll see something
remarkable in four to six to eight weeks
some of the people I've worked with
okay Glenn Frey down at age 67 from
ulcerative colitis again a gluten
intolerance she got to stay off of
gluten stay away from the bad stuff
these three Elvis Presley Michael
Jackson Karen Carpenter all died from
gluten intolerance secondary effects
Michael Jackson had bit alike oh he had
lost his skin pigment that's not his
hair as a wig his hair was snow-white he
shaved his head and and I had a wig on
all the time because his hair was white
and the skin was white he didn't bleach
himself he just didn't have any skin
pigment because he couldn't absorb the
minerals that required to make skin
pigment Elvis Presley died a card him
apathy heart-attack law he's on the
toilet trying to force a a a bowel
movement through when he was constipated
and Pam he died and Karen Carpenter was
legendary for having hiral bowel
syndrome this little you see on your
left here was barn goo mother who was 28
years old she had three miscarriages
already know the problem she had she had
eczema all over her face she had
constipation she had asthma and we put
her on a gluten-free diet she was she
was breastfeeding you see he was three
months old
the pediatrician told her to clip his
fingernails put mittens on his hands
that wouldn't scratch himself gave her a
a hydrocortisone cream to rub on him
soon when itch told her to keep
breastfeeding him because it was the
best milk for her never told her to get
off of gluten we've got on a gluten-free
diet got around the 90 and two weeks
later her asthma was gone her eczema was
gone the cheetah had for 28 years and
you see the same thing her breast mode
was his total food his asthma and eggs
went away in two weeks and here he is on
your right two years later fully two
years old now he is totally perfectly
free of all that stuff and he'll go on
to live to be 100 years old and so on
we see a lot of kids from Southeast Asia
and we have offices and warehouses in
Singapore so we serve everybody except
the North Koreans and maybe they need
the stuff maybe nice people you know who
knows I don't know but you can see on
the left here where they have eczema
they get psoriasis you put him on a
gluten-free diet you get him on the 90
and within weeks it's all back to normal
I have more kids with the same problem
this lady had the psoriasis for 23 years
her dermatologist made three million
dollars treating with UV light treatment
every week for 23 years
somebody needs to go to jail we put her
on a gluten-free diet cutter in the 90
cents of nutrients and in 90 days was
all gone after 23 years of suffering
according to Forbes magazine this is
March of 2011 the average lifespan of
billionaires is 66 the average lifespan
of billionaires is 66 that's because
they used the same personal trainers
that professional athletes use BAM
they're dead they are the most expensive
laboratory animals ever
I wonder what Steve Jobs his parents
thought when they buried him at age 56
I wonder what satoru iwata CEO of
Nintendo another billionaire who died at
age 55 I wonder what his parents thought
when they buried him at age 55 I wonder
what Vice President Joe Biden thought
when they buried his son Beau Biden at
age 46 I wonder what the king of Dubai
felt like when his son Sheikh Rashid
died at age 33 of a cardiomyopathy heart
attack while he was running I wonder
what former President Jimmy Carter felt
when his grandson Jeremy died at age 28
from a cardiomyopathy heart attack
I wonder what Pastor Rick Warren felt
like when his son died at age 27 from
suicide are you getting the picture here
now we as God's children have a huge
responsibility to our children who are
also God's children if we do not
supplement them you will be burying them
that's just the way it is
these are the four books you need to
digest and read for longevity every
black child in the world needs to read
this book black gene lies remember was
paid for by pastor dollar epigenetics
the death of the JUNK theories these
transmission in Marc Challon tells you
everything the top 20 longevity cultures
do to live longer than us they have 40
times 100 as we do they have 100 over
250 their population we only have one
per 10,000 they don't have doctors they
don't have roads they don't have
hospitals or clinics no pharmaceuticals
they have no health insurance and yet
they have 40 times 100 we do the whole
stories in that book and mortality rares
been cures is where those duck
experiments for the for the epigenetics
duck experiment was published and all
kinds of stuff you'll need to know we
think something is pretty good when
somebody lives be 102 107 didn't God say
the man all of men and women 120 are
average lifespan we take both men and
women at 74 that's almost 50 years shark
when you look at the language on the
national Geographics here on the
right-hand cover the left-hand cover
this baby will live to 120 in the middle
one this baby could live be 142 years
old russian-georgian the little brown
baby on your left is from the neckline
peninsula in Costa Rica Central America
and the little one on the right from
Russia and Georgia again in addition to
being the Garden of Eden I've been there
twice for the military there is such a
place
the first MapQuest is in the Old
Testament the Garden Eden is east of
Eden and there's four rivers that dump
into that valley Euphrates Tigris Pichon
Deshawn rivers that Valley is still
there the river still dumped into that
valley and then there's a land flowing
with milk and honey which is a month's
horseback ride or Trek from Jerusalem to
land flowing with milk and honey
certainly within the biblical range of
location is called Hunza the Hunza
Valley 13,000 foot elevation these are
the longest people on earth or a third
world culture and the the gilt star
glacier which is a mile wide the water
that comes out from underneath it looks
like milk it because it grinds up
limestone at 13,000 foot elevation which
is suspended in the water it looks like
milk coming out from underneath the
glacier you have more species of wild
bees and more wild honey than any place
else in the world because bees like
minerals the land flowing with milk and
honey these are the longest of people on
earth is documented by everybody
including the National Geographic
this gal here's the lead singer in a
rock group in Okinawa she's 97 years old
look at her energy for 97 this fella
here li ching-yuen who was born in 1677
died in 1933 his obituary his full
obituaries is in the book rare Sven
cures was also in the London Times in
the in the New York Times he died at 256
this is documented when he was 50 years
old he got a certificate from the
Emperor of China because he was very old
back then back then the average life it
was like in their 20s and so to live to
be 50 was outrageous and then when he
was a hundred they gave him another
certificate 150 game another suit if it
was 200 game another certificate was
gender fit he gave another certificate
now there's a whole University in the
place where he lived all they do is
study longevity may have all his
certificates hang on the wall may been
tested to show that they are the age of
the day that they are dated okay we're
down to the last say ten minutes here 10
15 minutes our body requires you've
heard me say this a couple of times our
bodies require essential nutrients we
call 90 for life 60 minerals 16 vitamins
12 amino acids 3 fatty acids and this is
what your genes your DNA or RNA in your
telomeres a little end caps in your
chromosomes require to maximize your
genetic potential for fitness and
longevity and health and making good
decisions and strength and speed and all
the things we tribute to you know to
genetics
your body needs these things an optimal
amounts if they're missing even 10%
you're going to get a horrible disease
if they're missing totally you're gonna
die if any one of them is missing
totally you will die
evander holyfield if your boxing fan you
know he had a a heart attack
kardama have a heart attack right in the
middle of a of a boxing match with
michael moore championship fight I'm the
guy that rebuilt him okay with the 90
essential nutrients plus the secret
sauce for the heart cardiomyopathy heart
disease Keshawn disease right sudden
even death syndrome and we were able to
rebuild him he came back in box for
eight more years at the championship
level Danny Glover had to give up action
movies because he had back problems and
hip problems we rebuilt him
90 essential nutrients and the secret
sauce for supporting promoting maintance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue just between a
vertebrae and so on bone matrix and now
he's back doing action movies I spent a
lot of time with pant Boone he is a
extremely godly man I just love him he
actually sang some songs to be in his
living room wonderful guy and he was
reduced to selling walk-in bathtubs
because he couldn't do anything because
of back and hip and knee problems well
now you don't see him selling bathtubs
anymore he's back on the road Willie
Nelson's on the road again because he
had to quit for many years because he
had arthritis in his fingers I was able
to rebuild him
Drew Pearson the Hail Mary pass receiver
from the Dallas Cowboys rebuilt his back
in hips and knees now he's one of our
top of so shit's working with youngevity
you come to our event she'll meet him
with a fabulous guy you've seen that so
I have to go into that again this is my
son's favorite picture as he's because
coming from the roosting area in the
jungles in the Amazon to eating the clay
on their way out to find bugs and nuts
and things to eat they're getting the
minerals from the clay that's why
they're so brightly colored if you want
your pet macaws and parrots and
parakeets to be really brightly colored
you give them our minerals as well as
the seeds they give you at the pet store
in that study I did with Marlon Perkins
20,000 excuse me 20,000 autopsies we
eliminated over 900 different diseases
using the information from those 20,000
autopsies we tripled the life span of
animals dogs 60 years ago live me an
average to eight now they're living 25
eliminate every birth defects you can
name in ten times that many you can't
and so I began to use it in people when
they fired me from Yerkes when I
discovered the cause French and cure of
city of roses I went back to school
became a physician and I began to use
everything I had learned on animals my
human patients guess what works it works
because all vertebrates are God's
creatures right and so the same thing
works for a turtle in a crocodile and a
giraffe and an elephant in a parakeet
and a flamingo
just like you and me we need these basic
things God got a good pattern and he
used the same pattern over and over and
over even an oak tree requires genes and
DNA to transfer information through the
Acorn to the baby oak trees how did rich
people get their minerals well pharaohs
and kings and successful generals and
successful merchants would pay grave
robbers great sums of money and silver
and gold to bring them mummies they'd
grind up the mummies and used the mummy
dust as a condiment like salt and pepper
and their food and yes what they were
healthier than the trolls living under
the bridge were just eating corn because
they were getting their minerals now
obviously poor people and slaves could
couldn't do that so how did poor people
and slaves get their minerals well the
common fuel of the the day back 5,000
years ago the universal fuel around the
world even though people could not
communicate ones living out in the
Pacific Islands and ones living in
Africa couldn't communicate the ones in
North America and so forth of South
America the Aztecs but the common fuel
around the world was wood and what did
they do with the wood ashes every
morning do they throw them in the and
the recycling bin to save the earth
no they threw him out in the garden well
it turns out that wood ashes are not
ashes 95 to 98 percent of the wood
answers minerals of the trees sucked up
out of the ground and the plants that
you fertilize with the wood ashes
actually sucked up the minerals and so
you ate these plants out of the garden
and you were getting the minerals from
the way nobody knew that nobody knows it
now you're knowing something only God
knows and now you've been given the
information you need to use it wisely
now that remains the same for thousands
and thousands of years until 3 o'clock
in the afternoon Monday September 4th
1882 on Pearl Street in New York City on
the bluff overlooking the construction
of Brooklyn Bridge this fellow here
Thomas Edison pulled the switch on the
first commercial electric generating
plant then 10 years every town every
municipality every city in the
industrialized world converted from what
is universal fuel to electricity
now how many wood ashes are left over in
your home every morning when you when
you fuel your home electricity none zero
now because nobody knew that was your
source of nutritional minerals nobody
supplemented here comes the government
here comes the doctors ojz well
you everything you need BAM you're dead
[Music]
now people like electricity did it again
it'll switch it among people like
electricity and so politicians jumped in
you vote for me I'm going to put up a
hydroelectric plant we're gonna have
electricity in this valley they did it
for the TVA they did it in the Colorado
River Valley in the southwestern seven
nations and we electrified these things
back in the late 1800s and 1910 the
1920s and people had jobs there was
money everywhere I mean people were rich
and we had factories and life was
booming it was wonderful but there was
unintended consequence how many ever
heard of flood control by these
hydroelectric dams uh-oh uh-oh
remember what fertilizes the Garden of
Eden flooding every year by the
tigris-euphrates Pichon Deshawn rivers
when water recedes what does it leave
behind silt mud which has minerals in it
did the farmer push that silt off to the
side before I planted no he plowed in
those metals again year after year after
year
well once we got hydroelectric plants to
make electricity
everybody's happy they had jobs
initially now comes the terrible part no
more mud no more silt after the flood
water receded because there's no more
floods so God's plan was interrupted
according to the World Health
Organization right now we have nine
hundred and sixty thousand dams damming
up the rivers our Sol's are depleted our
oceans are dying or oceans are dying yes
yes yes remember I wrote the first paper
on a mass die-off in americaland
pollution so I've kind of kept track of
this over the years pollution has
nothing to do with the oceans dying is
dying but this doesn't have to do with
the pollution we've cut off the food
supply to the ocean we dammed up all the
rivers for utilities no more silt going
to the ocean no more algae no more a
little plant somewhere fish no more us
so we're growing fish now in ponds with
GMO foods fed to the fish
whales are starving to death for lack of
food and washing up on the beaches now
sharks are attacking people in places in
every used to you can you remember
during the Beach Boy days and the
surfing days sharks attacking people
around Hawaii Southern California why
are they doing that now what was no fish
anymore for them to eat so you look
pretty good to them
nutritional minerals did not occur in a
uniform blank around the coast earth
they never did they always they occur
like chocolate and chocolate ice cream
some cases are blessed with a lot some
places are blessed with a few some
places don't have any well the people
who live the longest that's one of their
common features is they have lots of
minerals in their soil their food is
rich with minerals ok last couple of
slides this is what makes youngevity
different this is a compost pile that
has 78 minerals in it all 60 essential
metals and optimal amounts and this is
the core of everything we do in
youngevity these guys are standing on a
road 3,000 feet elevation above sea
level we have a hundred cubic miles of
this stuff we give tours of the place
and we're if nobody else has access to
this this is in perpetuity as long as
there's an earth nobody else will have
access to this place we're the only ones
I should tell you two minutes about her
she's been with us for 25 years in April
she'll turn 73 she most people think
she's 50 years old she owns quite a few
vineyards she's a large as VIN tour in
Michigan and grape vines around the
world usually will give you 50 60 pounds
of grapes per year hers give 250 pounds
cuz she's using these minerals from that
compost pile on her grapes she goes five
times a yield and the Amish use our
minerals for their sweet potato farms
they get 12 pound sweet potatoes one
sweet potato can feed a family of five
for a week now our cell is known to be
depleted in mineral since 1936 this was
the cause of the Great Depression and
the Dust Bowl our baby food just came
out in April of 2012 our baby foods
contained less than 20% of the required
minerals and bottoms necessary for
proper development dog food contains
100% chicken food it has 100
sheep pig cow food has 100 Center babies
and grandbabies have less than 20% go
read the mineral content to the baby
formalisms and pharmacies and grocery
stores they have less than 5 min err
allah some also have only three if you
don't supplement them you'll be burying
them hundred-year study 1914 to 2014
USDA reports that 95 percent of all
Americans are merely deficient the
minerals in ourselves over the past
hundred years are depleted by 85 percent
if you don't supplement if you don't
sell them at your kids you will be
burying them and you'll lose 25 to 50
years off your life ok getting down to
the last one or two slides here that
very quickly will make it in time
ok second last slide everybody needs in
19th century so we have a basic program
we call the Healthy Start pack it
contains three products has 245
nutrients in it including all 90
essential nutrients and optimized for
100 pounds of human flesh or month you
give this to a 50 pound kid it's a 2
month supply
give this to a 30 pound kids to three
month supply give this to a 200 pound
person you need two of these for month
one per 100 pounds of body weight per
month we have secret sauces for over 900
diseases some secret sauces will work on
over 150 diseases and of course we teach
you how the hell that works and so forth
and they're very simple the healthy
healthy weight loss packets or weight
loss is a healthy sports package for
people who sweat work hard physically
and we have the healthy digestive pack
and the healthy brain and heart pack
less self-explanatory the healthy bone
and joint packed healthy blood sugar
packet would you use that far diabetes I
mean this is not very difficult and we
have all kinds of products which I'm not
going to visit last slide people always
ask me doc what do you take I've been
taking the 90 centenarians twice a day
for 69 years I've been taking the 90
essential nutrients twice a day for 69
years I have not been sick in 69 years i
hemmed into a doctor medical doctor ever
I have never been on a prescription
medication I've never had any surgeries
now everybody can do that
because I'm getting the nutrition that
you would find in the Garden of Eden in
the land flowing with milk and honey
remember your genes your DNA or RNA and
your telomeres require this stuff to do
their job if you were to take dirt from
Texas and dirt from Alberta Canada
because there's you know these are where
the oil fields are and saying I'm not
gonna waste my money on oil I want to
put dirt from Texas dirt from Alberta in
there because everybody's knows there's
all in there that cargo three hundred
thousand miles by putting dirt in there
no and if you just eat salads with salad
dressings you eat processed meats on
your pizza with a gluten filled crust
and you're eating fat-free milk and
taking statin drugs Lori cholesterol and
you're eating egg beaters bam bam bam
you're dead okay what you see here on
the picture - about six products they
left about six products out this is a
two-week supply for me I do this twice a
month this is what I take I don't expect
everybody to do this if you just take
the 90 essential nutrients and avoid the
bad stuff you'll add 25 to 50 years your
life but if you want to live to be 120
you got to go a little stronger okay but
take the Healthy Start pack one per
hundred pounds of body weight and
obviously if you have certain diseases
you got to take a secret sauce at least
until the process is healed or goes away